Ou você aprende, ou você aprende, né?
Mas enfim, gente, sejam bem vindos ao terceiro dia do nosso Boot Camp.
Hoje a gente vai falar sobre.
O prisma de entrada de um engenheiro de dados e de um Analytics Engineer. Dentro do nosso projeto.
Então, só pra gente relembrar um pouquinho do que a gente está fazendo segunda feira, a gente entendeu qual é O Caso De Uso.
Que a gente está literalmente atacando aqui. A gente está construindo uma solução de Analytics moderna, de fim a fim.
O cliente que é o Northwind Pay, um dos problemas que eles têm. A gente está entrando num ambiente já existente.
é que eles têm uma camada legada, um Legacy Pipeline que basicamente você tem arquivos caindo no Sftp.
A gente tem uma aplicação de. De uma Thirty Party Application.
Que é Java.
Esse Java pega essas informações. Faça uma animação.
Faz o mascaramento dessas informações. Manda.
Para um Csv. E daí? Essas informações vão para o Postpress. Elas são carregadas em store procedures. E daí? O Pessoal Trabalha Nisso Né.
A grande questão que a gente está vendo aqui é como a gente faz a modernização disso. Via sistemas agênticos. Por Isso A Genetic.
O Ic no final.
E aí, o que acontece no final do dia.
Cada dia a gente vê um prisma. No primeiro dia, a gente vê um prisma de um arquiteto de soluções Junto Com O Ai Engineer Para Entender O Problema Como Um Todo E A Gente Se Colocou Na Lente Deles.
Revisando vários tipos de documento e criando lá os primeiros passos do Converge, que é o nosso Framework.
No dia dois, a gente olhou com a lente de um engenheiro de software abordando. Como ele vai fazer a escrita.
The Aplicação Java para a aplicação Python. Ontem, a gente passou exatamente por esse processo. Foi bem legal, porque a Gente Conseguiu Chegar Num Ponto.
Aonde a gente criou uma Steel thread. O que é um steel thread? é uma thread de aço ali, que Basicamente é A Parte Mais Importante Do Sistema Por Que A Gente Faz Isso é Como Se Fosse Um Mini Mvp.
Do nosso processo para garantir que a gente consegue.
Pegar o requisito, cortar ele em swim lanes, quebrar isso numa tarefa atômica, e executar um pedaço dessa tarefa para Ver Se Ela Funciona.
E a gente fez isso ontem, ou a gente vai fazer exatamente a mesma coisa. A gente ia construir a Steel Thread.
Para engenharia de Dados.
E o que é legal aqui, né?
Na terça e na quarta, a gente vai construir essas dreads na quinta feira. A gente vai deixar o quê? A Gente Vai Começar A Falar De Engenharia De Loop.
Ou seja, se na terça, na quarta. Hoje, a gente vai criar algumas tarefas iniciais.
Como esse fluxo vai funcionar quando a gente estiver tracionando ele constantemente.
Mas chegou um novo arquivo. A gente traduz esse cara.
Passa ele pelo processo valida ele no final, entrega.
Então a gente vai ter tudo isso dentro de um loop. Então amanhã vai ser exatamente quando a gente pega Todas Essas Tarefas E A Gente Coloca O Loop Dela.
Tá.
Aí. O Samuel está perguntando. Já vou para Python. Com que objetivo? Duzentos. Aqui vamos listar. Vamos listar uns vinte objetivos aqui.
A primeira coisa é que, normalmente, quando você fala de aplicações modernas que trabalham com dado, dificilmente você vai ver aplicações em Java.
Por vários motivos. O primeiro motivo é que profissionais modernos não escrevem. Java.
Principalmente com o cunho de pipeline de dados. Então, quando a gente olha hoje uma aplicação fim a fim.
Noventa dela vai precisar de um vértice de dados. Então, os profissionais hoje evitam escrever. Java.
Pela verbosidade, pela complexidade, por ser uma linguagem.
Muito boa para a engenharia de software.
Mas não um versátil para você trabalhar com dados e Analytics.
Segundo ponto, quando a gente olha para cientistas de dados, quando a gente olha para ai, Engineer, por exemplo.
Quando a gente olha para engenheiros de dados, a língua materna dessas pessoas são as Kelly Python.
Ou R, até muitas das vezes. E nunca java.
Terceiro ponto: quando a gente olha para Pipeline de dados como Spark, quando Bin, quando a gente usa outras tecnologias Que São De Processamento De Topo De Big Data.
A gente não usa Java também.
Outro ponto, quando a gente quer escalar Java em grande escala em microsserviços, funciona muito bem para conceito de microserviços como um todo.
Mas não tão flexível quanto a quantidade de pagam que a gente tem por ser. A gente sempre fala que O Python é Um Pato.
Ele não corre no nada.
E não voa bem.
Teoricamente, obviamente que existem algumas ramificações disso.
Mas a gente resolve sempre quando a gente está falando de modernização pela facilidade. Outro ponto.
Quando você está fazendo conternização de aplicações em Event Driven, por exemplo.
Eh: dificilmente você vai ver uma aplicação de Event Driven sendo escrita em Java, porque no final do dia.
Quem vai fazer manutenção nisso? é time de dados, tá ou time de engenharia de software moderno que evita utilizar Java.
Outro ponto, geralmente Java é extremamente complexo para você atualizar. Existem várias breaking changes entre versões do Java que quebram a aplicação.
Muitas dessas aplicações são vendidas por Third Party Applications, que são aplicações que foram, na verdade, construídas por um outro parceiro.
E geralmente isso custa muito caro para a empresa fazer isso. é um dos grandes motivos que você vê. Sistemas De Migração Sendo Realizados De Um Lado Para O Outro.
é porque Java se torna.
Um ponto muito, muito complexo.
Outro ponto, por ser uma linguagem que é compilada.
Isso traz também um outro nível de dificuldade no seu processo inteiro de Csd assim por diante. Então, quando a Gente Preza O Ciclo De Vida Hoje A Gente Olha As Empresas Mais Modernas Como.
Open. Ai.
Claudia, e assim por diante. Cara, a gente tá falando de Javascript, Python.
Basicamente é.
Alguma coisa extensível. Muito boa. Como ses. E mais mais. Talvez.
Mas dificilmente você vai olhar ambientes novos com linguagem Java, fim a fim.
Está muito dificilmente se você olhar pegar as aplicações modernas. Qual a porcentagem de escrita.
Você vai ver que na verdade existe pouco java. Tá.
Então espero ter respondido para você, Samuel. Então não faz sentido para a gente. Principalmente.
Então, Samuel, do Spark.
Ele é Java. Só que ninguém escreve java, né?
Então, assim uma coisa é você ter uma Engines que escreve em Java. Outra coisa é você escrever em Java são coisas diferentes.
Então, hoje, por exemplo, se a gente for olhar a Databrics e Spark noventa do código escrito hoje.
é escrito em Pythons.
Inclusive se você for escrever em linguagem baixa.
Eu não sei se todo mundo sabe disso, mas se você for escrever.
Em linguagem baixa.
No Spark. O meu Pie Spark vai dar no seu código de Spark cem vezes mais rápido.
Então, se você for escrever, por exemplo, se você for usar rdd para poder escrever hoje.
Você nunca vai ganhar. De uma linguagem de alto escalonamento.
Então impossível você ganhar.
Então são coisas diferentes. Uma coisa é uma coisa, outra coisa, outra coisa. O Spark hoje, do jeito que ele é construído.
Literalmente. A compilação dele está dentro de Java. Escala.
Só que hoje eles meio que não te possibilitam você escrever na Api baixa, porque não? Existem vários níveis de Otimização Que Você Tem.
E você vem por cima de data frame.
E aí? Ou deita sets. E esse cara faz abstração. Cria o plano tuxten. Gera todo o plano. Enfim, e é Muito Mais Otimizado Do Que Se Você Gerar Em Java Bike Code.
Então, assim.
Poderia ficar aqui nessa discussão. Mas no final das contas, realmente a gente não utiliza Java. Gente evita utilizar Java bastante.
Beleza. Então a gente vai fazer essa migração, tá? A gente vai sair de Java e a gente vai pra Python E A Gente Vai Entender Algumas Nuances Aqui Do Porquê A Gente Está Fazendo Isso Tá.
Marcelo perguntou se eu já fiz algum em Rust. Já fiz.
Russia. é uma.
Rash. é uma linguagem muito interessante.
Inclusive se você olhar hoje.
Para as bibliotecas mais escaláveis de Python. Você vai ver, na verdade, que o transpiler dela por debaixo dos planos é Rust.
Então eles escrevem Rust compilam isso.
E daí? Eles deixam essa abertura para você acessar via Python. Então Python tem um interpretador conectado direto para o Rust Que Você Consegue Fazer Isso.
E funciona muito, muito bem.
E tem várias outras bibliotecas também, que se comunicam com isso. Tá, então, Rush, é uma linguagem muito interessante. às vezes.
Não para você usar no primário, mas como backend.
Muito boa linguagem. Funciona muito bem. Tanto o Rust como o Gol.
Mas na vida real, a gente ainda tem.
Indiscutivelmente python, sendo.
O Go To para a Engenharia de Dados, ciências de Dados e a Engineering.
Então assim se você for olhar hoje, pô como que eu crio um reggae.
Pô. Se eu for olhar.
Como que eu utilizo essas bibliotecas. Você vai ver que cara sempre elas estão disponíveis majoritariamente em Java.
Type script assim por diante, tá? Mas as linguagens modernas mesmo beleza.
E a gente vai desempenhar exatamente essa ideia de trabalhar esse processo. Fim em fim, aqui.
Bem o que a gente fez ontem, né? Nós passamos aqui por seis. Eu diria seis grandes pedaços aqui.
é o primeiro. Foi literalmente a gente.
Quebrar o primeiro problema que a gente tinha numa cinma, que é cortar o sistema, ou seja.
Decompor um requisito muito grande em algo menor.
A gente começou a desenvolver.
O Java. Tá.
é.
O Java Two Pi. Java Power Pi. Então a gente escolheu esse nome.
A gente testou uma folha. Então a gente gerou uma tarefa.
Uma tarefa pequena para esse cara.
A gente entendeu, por exemplo, que existem arquivos que chegam.
E esses arquivos às vezes podem não estar corretos com o trailer, né?
Lembra lá, aqui dentro dos arquivos que a gente recebe do Sftp. Nós temos os detalhes que são somados.
Com Cobal Overpunt que muda os caracteres no final. E a gente tem o valor do trailer, que é a Soma Dos Dois às Vezes Pode Acontecer.
Que esse número não vem, correto?
Então você pode ter uma divergência. O que a gente entendeu na hora da nossa migração.
Que a gente não deve corrigir esse problema. Quem quiser abrir a câmera, até fica à vontade. Eu gosto de ver vocês.
Mas sim, na verdade, o que ele fez, classificar esse problema e não corrigir.
A gente identificou um pouquinho de binding. Também foi bem legal ontem, né?
Quem passou esse processo também. O Rafael mostrou um pouquinho do processo de como o Cláudio estava evitando.
Literalmente fazer qualquer modificação no ambiente, porque existia no Rhidming.
this guitar.
que.
A key…
Agent pro mundo.
Ta.
Un chimi.
De presolos para.
Pizza para one size pizza.
X. Ai, literalmente. Spacex. Como que é Moon Shot? Trabalha.
Eu gosto muito, sempre de tentar puxar essas informações e entender um pouquinho como eles trabalham.
Desculpa. E se vocês olharem.
A gente está exatamente no caminho certo.
Então o que eu estou mostrando para vocês aqui real, muita gente já faz.
Talvez muita coisa que eu falei. Você já faz.
E aí existe uma coisa da gente fazer e da gente idealizar. Isso acontece no meu dia a dia. às Vezes Eu Faço Um Bocado De Coisa E Depois Eu Falo Hum.
Caraca. Olha, mudou realmente isso aqui.
E a gente idealiza, né? Então.
Acho que durante essa semana vai ficar muito claro que a gente está caminhando para esse caminho aqui.
Poxa o quão o Brasil está longe disso.
E aí obviamente que eu vou deixar isso para você responder. Me responde aí no chat.
O combo. Você acha que o Brasil está longe.
De ter essa consciência aqui.
Se já. Acho que já existem empresas no Brasil.
Fazendo esse movimento, demitindo em massa.
Reduzindo, compactando.
Roles dentro da empresa, como, por exemplo.
Vou dar um exemplo do Nubank. O Nubank recentemente anunciou que não existe mais área de dados. Teoricamente, não existe Mais Profissionais De Dados Dentro Do Nubank.
Essa profissão foi condensada em uma como sofre Engineer.
Então, hoje o time de dados precisa saber. Engenharia de software. Eles têm aproximadamente entre seis meses a um ano para se adaptar.
Caso eles não se adaptem.
Enfim, então assim eu acho.
Que quando a gente olha para isso.
E a gente pensa que isso está muito distante.
Eu quero falar o seguinte para vocês.
Talvez esteja distante.
No seu ecossistema, mas está mais perto de você do que você imagina. Por exemplo, você pode ser o driver Da Cultura Que Vai Fazer Isso.
Olha só! Que loucura, né.
Quem concorda com isso? Eu fui o driver dentro da pfia. Olha que coisa louca, né?
Dentro de uma empresa fora do país. E o Fluidriver disso.
Eu fui o cara que literalmente meteu as caras.
Levantou a mão.
Falou que, em vez de três, quatro engenheiros, a gente conseguia fazer isso somente como um engenheiro. E num Devops.
E a gente entregou do outro lado. A gente está falando de um projeto há dois anos e meio atrás.
Imagina hoje. Então, né.
Então, hoje, literalmente, eu não preciso de ninguém. Graças a Deus. Estou brincando. Preciso sim. é sempre bom trabalhar com Pessoas De Vez Em Quando.
Quando elas são inteligentes.
Quando elas são animaizinhos de teta. Não é muito legal? Não, mas com relação à inteligência, é muito foda. Atrapalhar.
Mas brincadeiras à parte.
A grande ideia é que obviamente pô isso quer dizer, Luan, que você vem do background de engenharia de dados. Você Vai Saber Mais Que Um Devops.
Claro que não. Nunca. E aí nunca é nunca, né? Você pega. Por exemplo, o Daniel, que trabalha no meu Time, que é Brasileiro. Também Ele Tem Dezassete Anos De Thevops De Infredops Cara.
Como que eu vou bater com um cara desse nunca, né? Isso tá embedado dentro dele.
Mas em algum momento, ele vai ter que trabalhar com dados também. Como ele teve que trabalhar nesse último projeto Que Ele Fez Da F Cinto.
Então poxa. Aquele Skill dele já é um pouco menor.
Mas ele vai conseguir se virar. Se ele tem um mindset de um sênior, ele consegue qualquer sênior cara que vem.
Da engenharia de Dados. Ou vem da Engenharia de Ia.
Ou vem, cara de engenharia de software, ou vem de Devops. A infraestrutura que a pessoa é sênior.
Eu digo, qualquer senhor consegue se virar muito bem com essa nova ideologia. Aqui.
Okay.
Então vamos ver aqui que eu tenho aqui.
Construir as pessoas que conversam muito longe. Talvez.
Grandes empresas como Ifood. Sim, outra coisa que ficou bem claro, pelo menos para mim, a importância de uma excelente Discovery Com O Negócio Antes De Iniciar Qualquer Processo Com Ia Muito Bom Amor.
Eu diria que isso aqui é Sim, se você tiver isso na cabeça, cara, é jogo ganho basicamente, tá.
Porque o seu tempo vai ser aqui.
Compactando. Eu vim na Pad, principalmente quando escutava.
Faça sua mágica.
Eu estou tentando. Estou sendo na minha área que a empresa está bem perto. Não, eu nunca usei layoff. Não.
Por favor, de leves.
Alguém tem que causar. Eu trabalho para uma empresa do Qi, e lá os Devs estão fazendo cara feio para Usar A Gente Engineer Mas Essa Semana Já Vieram Perguntar.
Como o tempo limitado, meus works items e fazendo code review. Engraçado.
Eu acho que logo mais. Quem é mais velho no mercado antes de fazer de tudo hoje.
Se você tem essa flexibilidade com Ia, pode fazer também.
A empresa. O pessoal está sendo obrigado a usar ai usar Spec driven Cloud Code e Github Copilot. Obrigado, é ótimo.
No Brasil. Eu ouço bastante sobre empresas demitindo, porém, parece que estão tendo pouco retorno produtivo com os da Ia.
E muito gastos de Token. Eu também escuto isso.
E aí eu acho que vai muito dos profissionais do que literalmente da Ia. Tá.
Lo. Passei três anos.
Pensando: como vou criar um app e colocar ele para rodar com Ia em três meses no ar? Isso é Uma Outra Coisa Muito Legal Que Você Falou Aqui.
Que eu tenho um caso muito legal. Também eu trabalhava com um Vp.
Miles Trenchberg e Cara.
Ele era sítio. Ele foi sítio durante vinte anos.
Então ele conhecia muita dor de um City.
Cara. E aí ele começou a fazer um vibe coding de uma aplicação. Que cara? Ele achava que era muito Foda E Olha, A História.
E daí? Ele vai para o Kodoma uma solução no raplet, que é uma das ferramentas de A bem legal Que Funciona Você Consegue Fazer Deployment Você Consegue.
Na verdade, ter tudo dentro dele.
E ele me mostrou chamado Candela.
Ele me mostrou esse produto dele, que fazia controle de Cto e assim por diante. Orquestração das atividades. Quem estava fazendo o quê.
Eram Tools. Uma ferramenta.
E ele mostrou a versão inicial. Três meses depois, ele me mostrou.
Uma versão que já estava muito mais limpa. Funcionando bem. Legal.
E o cara acabou de receber um funding de doze milhões de dólares.
Tá? Então, só para vocês entenderem um pouquinho como que as coisas são loucas. Então.
Quanto mais domínio você tem de uma coisa mais fácil você literalmente criar algo.
E se você tiver expertise técnica, então você vai muito longe.
Então a ideia tendência é todo mundo ser engenheiro de software, inclusive engenheiro de A. é. A ideia é a Gente Ser Esse Conceito De Ai Nature Engineer.
E aí vão ter vários nomes em cima disso de software que sabe aveia de dados, que sabe a.
Vai ser um Ai Engineer que sabe a. Vai ser um cientista de dados que sabe a.
Né.
Porque o mercado não tem uma definição disso.
A maior definição que a gente tem hoje no mercado.
São duas, tá? Que é o Applied ai Engineer.
Então esse nome é muito forte lá fora.
Que é o cara que literalmente faz isso. E a gente está vendo num escopo.
Um pouco menor aqui. Eu estou extrapolando algumas curvas para mostrar para vocês o quão possível é.
Fazer vários trabalhos desempenhados como você, orquestrando.
Mas tem um outro ponto muito importante, que é.
O conceito de fooder Fdw, Né.
Fde, que é o Forward.
Deployed Engineer. Esse nome está assim completamente.
Explodindo.
Então, basicamente, é o cara que tem a inteligência do negócio.
Das soluções técnicas.
E ele é depoiado dentro do cliente.
E aí ele trabalha dentro do ambiente do cliente. Com o conhecimento do cliente.
Só que ele tem todo o quê? A solução técnica na mão. E agora, com o Iá, você consegue fazer isso?
Então isso tem explodido bastante lá fora também.
Luan. A empresa de trabalho vem como ensin, diretor. Alguns meses. Está funcionando.
De ouvir você falar que mistura é muito cada um no seu quadrado e limitado à sua função.
Aqui no Br. é muito. O cara faz tudo como está no exterior com Ia.
Essa é uma boa pergunta.
As empresas começaram a ver, né? E esse é um movimento que eu nunca imaginei que ia acontecer.
Americanos virando mais generalista. Eu nunca tinha visto isso acontecer. E pensei que isso nunca ia acontecer. Sendo bem sincero.
E o que a gente vê hoje é exatamente isso. Mas não é se generalista do jeito que a gente vê no Brasil.
é um cara que começa a ter uma amplitude maior, um chão maior para tocar um espaço maior para tocar.
Então ele começa. Na verdade, ele começa. Não, né? Eu falava há um tempo atrás, em alguns treinamentos meus.
Que eu sou da época não tão tão distante há um ano atrás, que a galera falava assim. Poxa, Luana.
Eu estou usando Ia, mas o meu time não entende. O meu chefe não entende. E tal, tal tal tal Tal Tal Tal Agora, A Gente já Tá Tipo Assim.
Meu chefe. Uma empresa quer produtividade. Eles têm mandatos de ato me obrigando a usar Ia. Eu tenho que usar. Ia. Então.
Você vê que de um ano pra cá muita coisa mudou.
E aí o que você começa a entender, na verdade, que agora está vindo de cima para baixo, não de baixo, para cima, e quando vem de cima para baixo, as coisas tendem realmente a acontecer De uma forma ou De outra.
Porque mexe no dinheiro. E aí, por exemplo, por que mexe no dinheiro? Se você pega uma empresa de consultoria, Por Exemplo Para O Meu Trabalho.
Você acha que para eles é mais lucrável botar dez engenheiros de dados num projeto de três milhões ou botar Dois Engenheiros De Dados Sênior.
Pagar um quinto do valor e ter uma margem de lucro muito maior. Isso se aplica a todas as outras Vertentes Também Então Se Você Pega Os Profissionais Que Se Destacam.
E se você olha um pouquinho como é a hierarquia do trabalho?
Hoje, cara. Um sênior consegue desempenhar o trabalho de dois, três, no mínimo.
Plenos, no mínimo, plenos.
Tá? E aí? Nem falando. Isso do Júnior.
Então, cada vez mais a gente vê no mercado. E aí vai acontecer, como sempre acontece, um modelo cíclico disso. Mas, enfim.
A gente já vê muita coisa acontecer.
é.
Hoje tem um time de Team e tem devies que não querem migrar e usar a fragilidade. Boa sorte.
Não. Será que eu estou louco? Mas acho que engenharia de dados está menos ameaçada que a engenharia de software. Só uma percepção.
Bem, a minha opinião sobre isso é que.
E eu sou muito feliz de ter escolhido engenharia de dados.
Pelo fato do seguinte: se você olhar.
Os Cientistas de Dados.
O que aconteceu com esse profissional, né?
Subcional ganha muito bem. Ainda.
Ele é super valioso, mas o engenheiro. Mas o cientista de dados clássicos hoje.
Ele tem muito menos vaga.
Se você olha hoje, por exemplo, um engenheiro de Machine Learning Engineer.
Também parou muito no tempo. Se você olhar engenharia de software, é o que llm está fazendo.
Se você olha dados.
Na minha percepção. Não, porque eu trabalho com dados. Eu acredito muito que.
O dado é derivado, né?
Empresa derivada pelo dado. Então.
Inevitavelmente dados ao centro de qualquer empresa.
Porque você precisa analisar, tratar e literalmente entregar valor com dados.
Então, se você conversar hoje com um engenheiro de software.
A gente teve a semana da engenharia. A gente. O Algimar tem vinte e dois anos de engenharia de software. Se Você Perguntar Para Ele O Seguinte Algimar.
Hoje.
Da porção das coisas que você faz de microserviços. Enfim, tal.
Você precisa trabalhar com tecnologias de dados.
Você precisava fazer isso. Há dez anos atrás.
Data vai te respondeu o seguinte. Não hoje eu preciso absolutamente. Eu preciso pensar no microsserviço.
Que transborda o dado para um local que vai fazer uma análise assim.
Que quando precisar processar esses microserviços, que eu sei que uma linguagem de progressão não vai fazer. Eu vou passar Isso Para O Spark.
Eu vou colocar isso dentro de um Storage para poder processar. Então, hoje, o engenheiro de dados precisa ter consciência Do Ambiente De Dados.
Assim como o engenheiro de dados precisa ter consciência do software.
Por isso que eu falo cada vez mais que essas coisas vão.
Se juntar.
O fde.
Ele geralmente é mais para consultoria. Quem trouxe muito desse termo foi a Palanti a sete, oito anos atrás. Mais ou menos.
Que ela falava realmente de fazer o Deployment dos seus engenheiros dentro.
Dos clientes aí no caso, porque eles trabalhavam com realmente Pentágono, exército americano e assim por diante. Então eles tinham Que Colocar O Engenheiro Lá Dentro.
Mas a grande ideia é que esse engenheiro vinha como todo treinamento técnico.
Ele era depoiado dentro do cliente para resolver o problema dele. Não uma demo.
Uma coisa que funcionou em outro cliente, mas sim uma coisa que ia funcionar dentro dele.
Trabalho para fora e temos plataformas desenvolvidas internamente, já que ajuda os Devs, engenharia no fluxo inteiro Dev dados a criar tudo.
Somente com linguagem natural, desde a tarefa com gira, infra pipe, modelagem, feature Bent, alerta até o deploy e cada vez mais.
O que o Brian falou aqui vai acontecer, tá? Nos últimos meses. Eu tenho. Acho que eu fiz, sei lá.
Oito, nove diferentes clientes.
Falando de infraestrutura de ar.
Então isso é uma tendência? Com certeza.
O que a gente viu ontem, né? No nosso repositório ontem.
A gente acabou com alguns.
Documentos. Dentro desse repositório, a gente vai ver isso em mais detalhes ao longo do dia. Hoje.
Mas aqui a gente terminou. Se a gente abrir docs, né?
A gente acabou primeiro, né?
A gente gerou um documento de requisito que veio de vários documentos do cliente.
Depois desse documento, foi gerado um documento de especificação técnica para o que a gente tinha que implementar do tipo um.
Inicialmente. Depois disso, a gente passou isso dentro do converge. O Converge quebrou isso em Ad.
Que são.
Arquitetura. Decision Records.
Os registros do que são extremamente importantes.
Como explicação, com texto, porque consequências e, principalmente, a evidência que te aponta isso.
E a gente gerou um documento também de contexto.
Aonde eu tenho todos os jargões.
Informações, localização.
E assim por diante. Então, quem fez todo esse processo pra gente de forma transparente?
Foi o converge. Foi um framework que eu desenvolvi para fazer isso.
Mas no final do dia, você poderia pedir para ele? Nm: Assim, de forma bem genérica.
ó, pega esse bando de coisa e transforma num documento.
De negócio pô. Pega agora esse documento de negócio e extrai os valores para criar um documento técnico.
Agora, com esse documento técnico, quebra isso em Adrs, para que eu possa ter rastrabilidade e ter cada uma dessas decisões separadas atomicamente.
Ou seja, eu estou decompondo o meu trabalho. Então a gente viu esses dois caras ontem, né?
E aí? Hoje a gente vai sentar na cadeira de um Analytics Engineer.
E de um dear engineer pergunta: qual a diferença entre essas duas bowls? Na sua opinião.
O que um da faz e o que um de faz. Basicamente.
Coloquei no chat.
Quando vocês colocam aí. Basicamente, eu separei alguns pontos que são extremamente importantes. Tá.
Gosto do que o Samuel falou aqui. O de analisa e o de executa. Essa é uma boa forma de.
De colocar essas duas voos.
Data está mais perto de infra data, mais perto de business. Muito bom. Também.
Acho que data mais próximo do negócio. Enquanto der a mais próxima da infra, meu irmão.
De análise de dados deve fazer ingestão de dados exatamente também.
Então dá para entender essa segregação. Muito bem.
Por exemplo, de transporta e ajusta faz. Traz valor para o negócio.
Então essas duas Rolls.
Mas aí deixa eu perguntar para você uma pergunta mais complexa. Por que você acha que existem essas duas Rolls.
Na sua opinião.
Que um profissional, por exemplo, um da não pode fazer tudo. Não conseguiria fazer tudo muito bem.
Ou por que um deno conseguiria fazer tudo bem. O que difere eles? Para que nós.
Por exemplo, ter duas pessoas desempenhando.
Porque o Da pode não ter conhecimento técnico.
Porque o dai de business, por exemplo.
Opção.
Pela quantidade de tarefas serem executadas. Permissão de acesso.
No passado. Um falar com a máquina para entregar o dado e o outro com o negócio. São disciplinas distintas.
Então tudo isso que vocês falaram faz totalmente sentido, né?
Acho que é mais o foco do profissional.
Geralmente, quem tem veia mais técnica. Se por der quem tem um veia mais business vai por da.
Cunhada fazer a parte de. De a entregar um App com Stranger.
Porque eu deito unicórnio. Não existe com certeza nenhum unicórnio existe, né? A gente nunca viu ele andando.
Nem voando, nem por aí.
Mas a grande ideia é o seguinte.
Tem uma Gina. Vou mudar um pouco o prisma.
Aqui só para vocês entenderem.
Se você tem um time de um Solutions, Architect.
Que faz o quê? Coordenar.
Se você tem um, de que implementa.
E se você tem um da que.
Fala com o cliente.
Ou né.
Mostra para o cliente.
O que é essa? O que essas três me mostram aqui, né?
Que o da também.
I tro de deitar na lista, né.
E a gente tem um outro cargo também. Ali, no meio, chamado Analítics Engineer. E eu acho muito legal esse Cargo Ter Explodido Tanto.
O que para vocês é um Analytics Engineer.
Beleza. O Daily Engineer e o Data Analyst ficou completamente claro.
E agora a gente está olhando o Data Engineer e o Analytics Engineer.
Qual a diferença desses dois caras? Porque são exatamente desses dois caras que a gente vai falar.
Em breve chegamos no King Kong.
Um bi mais técnico Ae foca em produtos de dados.
Tentativa de juntar as duas Skills. Muito bom, Jonathan. Eu gosto muito disso. Aí.
Tentativa falhada miseravelmente tentar unir essas duas. Que é exatamente isso? Tá.
O analista engenheiro nasceu para juntar essas duas profissões. Tá.
Ele nasceu por causa disso.
Que é uma pessoa que.
Entendia. Negócio.
Entendi os conceitos mais básicos do final do túnel, que é um warehouse de dados.
O que é um processo de Etl assim por diante.
Por isso que o Dbt explodiu, né? Porque a proposta do Dbt era justamente falar o quê, Etel e Les, Né Teoricamente Cara Você Conectava O Dbt No Dayware Housing.
E você basicamente teria todo o processo fim a fim funcionando.
Então essa era a grande ideia.
Obviamente que não existe One Size Fits All.
Mas a ideia foi basicamente esse, né.
Paga. Um, ganha dois.
Mas, no final das contas, quando a gente olha hoje no mercado, hoje, um engenheiro de dados faz muita parte, como.
Alguém falou que eu acho que a Ju falou.
Da ingestão do dado da transformação do dado.
Até a sua camada Gold, por exemplo. E ali o Analis Engineer vai se conecta.
Nessa parte da Gold. Ou trabalha juntamente com o Danny Engineer na Gold.
Para poder mostrar o que o cliente precisa.
E aí? Hoje.
Na nossa perspectiva aqui, de a.
O que a gente precisa garantir.
A gente precisa garantir que.
Todo mundo fala, né? Eu acho engraçado expor.
Soft Skill Communication Skills é uma Skill que você tem que aprender, cara.
Acho que você não tem muita opção, né?
Porque a gente fala com pessoas.
Via comunicação, né? Então assim não tem muito como fugir disso. Você vai ter que.
Cada vez mais, aprender a se comunicar.
Muito bem, então.
Hoje, se a gente falar tecnicamente.
De um engenheiro de dados e de um.
Analytics Engineer não tem nada que um agente não possa fazer. O que ele não pode fazer é literalmente se Comunicar Com O Cliente.
Então você vai fazer o papel exatamente esse. Mas a parte de construção. Ele pode ser feita por um agente.
Então cada um aqui.
Ele vai olhar o problema com prismas diferentes.
Ele vai ter granularidades.
Do problema também ele vai ver tabelas e conceitos de uma forma em que o engenheiro de dados vai ver.
Enquanto analista, um analista de dinheiro vai olhar muito mais no conceito de granularidade.
Teste.
é uma coisa extremamente importante, porque a gente está falando de um pipeline.
Que tira uma herança de muitas coisas importantes que a gente tinha na área de dados, que eram tabelas, por Exemplo Com Foreign Keys Com Primary Keys.
Constraintes que garantiam que cara, um dado não poderia entrar nulo numa coluna.
Com um valor deveria ser positivo e assim por diante. Normalmente em ambientes de big data.
Você tem que fazer isso de forma mais rústica.
Um outro ponto é como que o garanto. A verdade.
Então lembra que toda vez que a gente constrói uma solução nesse calibre, a gente sempre tem que garantir qual é O Resultado Final.
A gente tem que saber qual o resultado final.
E aqui. Nesse caso, o que a gente quer garantir é.
Se eu receber um valor ou um arquivo em que eu vá trabalhar, esse arquivo.
E que esse arquivo esteja diferente da regra final.
Eu não vou simplesmente resolver esse problema. O que eu vou fazer na verdade, é levantar esse problema.
E aí uma das coisas muito importantes da gente entender no conceito de Engenharia de dados de analíticas e Engineering.
Por exemplo, o conceito de grão. Isso é uma coisa que a gente usa muito.
O engenheiro de dados. Normalmente tá.
Normalmente ele tem um conhecimento.
De Day Housing. Então, quando a gente fala de Day Re Housing, impossível você não ter utilizado ter ouvido falar.
Desconceito de grão.
Com a granularidade do dado com a granularidade daquela pesquisa.
No nosso caso, a nossa granularidade.
é o Beth, por exemplo, que é o Betty.
Do arquivo, mais o Currency. Então os dois combinados me diz realmente qual é o grão.
Porque eu posso ter. às vezes o mesmo Batch de arquivo com currencies diferentes. Por isso que eu preciso de uma granularidade.
Nível Batch. Tá.
Outra coisa. Contrato.
Esse contrato aqui. é uma coisa interessante da gente discutir um pouquinho.
Contrato é para garantir.
Basicamente o que significa, certo.
Então a gente veio dia um dia dois falando de contrato.
Que você precisa saber o que define, certo.
Então o contrato que você deve criar, independentemente do que você está fazendo, principalmente com sistemas agênicos, vai garantir, cara.
Qual é a definição de certo? A gente vai ver isso um pouquinho, tá.
Depois, Beth vai processar em conjuntos de tabelas em conjuntos.
De dados, e a gente tem o conceito de pipeline de dados. Obviamente que eu acho que todo mundo aqui Conhece Qual O Conceito é.
E aí, o que a gente vai ver ao longo desse dia, a gente vai ver não só as escolhas Que Nós Fizemos Aqui Mas O Porquê Das Coisas.
Normalmente na vida real.
Muitas vezes.
é você que decide a Stack que você vai trabalhar? Projeto. Ele chega até você.
E obviamente por você ser especialista em alguma coisa. Você simplesmente é assinalado.
Para fazer isso. Então aqui a gente está pensando um pouquinho de coisa um pouquinho sobre isso.
Já existem coisas que foram assinaladas e dadas para a gente. Meio que herdou esse plano.
Então a gente vai se adaptar nisso. E vai fazer isso baseado nos conceitos. Porque a ideia aqui.
Não é a gente entender. Engenharia de dados é a ideia, daqui a gente tentar entender como a gente aborda.
Engenharia de dados de forma agêntica, como que a gente transforma esse processo.
De forma agêntica. E aí, aqui no pipeline de dados. é interessante, porque, por exemplo.
Quando você fala de.
Decompor um problema.
O pipeline de dados é interessante, porque você pode decompor de várias formas.
Então, por exemplo, a gente tem ali.
A entrada do dado que pode ser uma decomposição.
A gente tem a parte de ingestão de dados, que também pode ser uma decomposição.
A gente tem a parte do Lake Housing onde o dado vai ser armazenado. O local, que também pode ser uma decomposição.
A gente tem a quebra do Dbt juntamente com Bronze Silver e Gold, que também pode ser uma decomposição.
E a gente tem também o valor da verdade que vai ser validado contra isso.
Então, quando a gente começa a olhar como a gente vai quebrar esse pipeline.
A gente precisa entender.
O que cada tecnologia representa para a gente aqui, dentro do nosso ambiente.
Então, o Dlt, por exemplo, quando a gente olha aqui. Python Dlt? Não sei. Muita gente não conhece, tá.
Uou.
O Dlti. Uma tecnologia bem interessante em Python, na verdade, que ele é obviamente, tudo agora é nativo de Engenharia.
Mas basicamente, você consegue criar pipelines de movimentação de dados via Python.
E ele tem várias coisas interessantes aqui.
Do que ele consegue fazer. Ele consegue trabalhar com trilhões de ingestões. Ele consegue fazer diversas transformações.
Consegue fazer vários pipelines, e a gente escolheu. Ele obviamente, foi escolhido ele, justamente pelo processo de ser tudo local.
Que pode ser deployed na nuvem. Meu áudio está ruim. Pessoal.
Ou tá tudo bem.
Então a gente pode ter esse cara que vai ser colocado na nuvem. Mas a grande questão para a gente Poder Testar O Ambiente Como Um Todo é Que Tudo Pode Ser Colocado Local.
Mas se a gente olhar aqui, tudo pode ir para a nuvem. Então, por exemplo, o Dlt, você tem Cloud.
O Duct Tb. Você pode mandar ele para o Moderb.
Moderate, Tp, Moderduct, Tp.
Você manda ele para cima. Dbt: você tem um Dbt cloud, ou você tem um composer ou qualquer outra coisa.
Então todas essas tecnologias que a gente vai fazer. Local.
Elas podem ser colocadas na nuvem, o que é ótimo.
Porque isso possibilita para a gente poder testar. Então a gente vai ter o Dlt como Register ou como Ingester.
A gente vai armazenar essas informações no Ductb. A gente vai conectar o Dbt com o Ductb para receber essas Informações E Começar A Trabalhar Elas.
E a gente vai ter um Judge que vai julgar o que é certo e o que é errado.
Por isso que a gente precisa do Golden Match, né?
Do dataset escrito por Deus. Nesse caso, como a gente está fazendo a migração de um ambiente que já existe, A Gente Tem Esse Resultado Já.
Só tem uma coisa interessante aqui.
A gente sabe.
Que o movimento da tecnologia.
Engloba uma grande parte de dados.
E a gente viu isso aqui acontecer diante. Tem muita gente aqui que viu isso acontecer.
Na época de dois mil de terror Housing, depois de dois mil e dez de Day Lake, depois de dois Mil E Vinte De Day Lake House.
Então muita gente passou.
Por esses processos. E o que a gente entendeu hoje é que.
Eu não conheço nenhum projeto de dados que não utilize Lake Housing. Cara, eu realmente. Eu desconheço.
Cliente Médio Grande. Eu desconheço total. Nunca entrei numa call com um cliente que ele não soubesse que é Lake House.
O que ele já não tivesse ou não falasse de bronze sever. Então assim.
Se você não tem um background de engenharia de dados, mas você nunca quer errar.
Estúdio Lake House. E obviamente, você vai ter que estudar um pouquinho de Daily Housing. Um pouquinho de Daily Lake.
He did a Lake House para entender o que significa.
Mas todas as arquiteturas que eu conheço.
Independentemente da tecnologia que você for usar.
Utiliza o leque House.
E aí, quem trabalha com dado.
Isso é bem Bread and Butter. Isso é bem pão com manteiga. Então, o que a gente tem aqui, né?
Na nossa arquitetura, que a gente vai avaliar logo mais.
E aí imagina que tem um arquiteto de soluções apresentando esse problema para vocês.
A gente tem três pernas aqui, né? A primeira perna é quando eu recebo o dado que vem da Landing Zone.
Então imagine que vai acontecer, Sftp.
O engenheiro de software vai traduzir o Java para o Python.
Esse Python vai escrever em parque numa Landing Zone. Então esse é o trabalho.
Do engenheiro de software recebeu Java.
Criar a mesma aplicação em Python moderna.
E escrever em vez de Csv. Escrever em parquê.
Quando esse dado bate na camada Landing lá do Sftp.
A gente vai ter uma ingestão que vai colocar isso dentro.
To Duckdb. E a gente vai utilizar a. O quê? Bronze Silver e Gold.
O que a gente tem na bronze. O pessoal de dados já é cansado de ver isso. Principalmente se vocês Já Fizeram Vários Treinamentos Comigo.
There's. Eu não aguento mais falar de Bron Silvio Gloody. Graças a Deus que as pessoas já sabem o que é isso.
Eu não preciso mais falar. Eu já falei tanto disso que realmente eu me sinto. Até eu fico incomodado de falar tanto disso.
Mas engraçado que ainda existem várias nuances aqui. Tá, mas enfim.
O que você tem aqui.
Você tem a maturidade do dado. Basicamente, você está maturando o dado.
E você está mudando viés de interpretação dessa informação ao longo.
Dos passes desse dado. Então, quando você está no bronze.
A gente chama ele de Source Aligned. Porque ele está alinhado com a fonte. Ele tem que ser exatamente igual.
Por vários motivos. O principal motivo.
é que, em algum momento, se você precisar reprocessar.
Se você precisar ter auditoria.
Se você precisar.
Se você precisar incrementar valores. Se você precisa ter um local imutável onde ele não muda. E que diga a história da fonte.
Porque às vezes a fonte pode ser o dado. Pode ser excluído lá na fonte. Num banco de estados relacional, Você Pode Ter Um Purge De Dado E Perder Aquela Informação.
Então a bronze. O que ela vai fazer? Ela vai ser o dado exatamente.
Igual. Esse cara.
Para entrar no Leak House.
Bem. Daqui para cá.
A gente tem o mesmo grão.
Muitas das vezes.
Que a gente vai limpar esse dado. Então, nesse primeiro momento, a gente tem tabelas, despesas.
E aqui a gente vai conformar os grãos, né?
Por que é conformar os grãos? é começar. Talvez se você tem, por exemplo, cinco tabelas bronze.
Você vai convergir isso em duas tabelas. Silvers, por exemplo, se você tem três tabelas bronze, vamos dar um exemplo Aqui Muito Simples Tá.
Gente. Eu vou parar aqui as vezes que minha garganta está assim.
Está insuportável.
Bem perto do insuportável. O que acontece.
Na Bronze. Vamos pegar um exemplo muito bom, que eu gosto de usar.
Hoje. Você tem micro serviços, né? E imagino que você tem um usuário vendendo Bongo.
Um usuário vindo do posters e uma tabela de usuário vindo do mais quer. Então você tem três tabelas de usuário.
Na bronze. Por quê? Se você tiver duzentos tabelas na Landing.
A ideia é que você tenha duzentos tabelas na bronze. Tá.
Só que na hora que você for para a Silver.
Que. Que a gente vai fazer falar. Olha, poxa, eu tenho um usuário vindo do Post Price.
Usuário vindo do mais Kelly usuário vindo do Mongo. Db pô.
Para que eu vou ficar pesquisando isso toda vez, sendo que o meu negócio quer saber. Por exemplo, o usuário X pelo Cpf.
Let me a camada Gold Engineer. Ele quer pesquisar essa informação já governada em um local só de fácil acesso.
Por que a gente faz na camada Gold? Na camada? Silvia.
A gente conforma essa informação. A gente junta essas informações.
E cada passado dessa aqui.
Eu tenho regras de qualidade.
Então eu vou testar a granularidade. Eu vou verificar se aquele dado está certo ou não.
No nosso caso, se a gente achar um problema, a gente não vai literalmente.
Parar o pipeline. Mas muitas das vezes que a gente vai fazer, vai criar uma área de quarentena para colocar Essa Informação Guardada Em Algum Lugar.
E o dado aqui é muito importante. Tá?
Ele ainda não perdeu a granularidade. Ele continua na mesma granularidade.
E no mesmo tipo de visão. Aqui você tem uma visão operacional.
Aqui. Você continua tendo uma visão operacional quando você sai da Silver, e você vai para o Gold.
Você começa a mudar.
O sentido do dado. Então ele sai de uma visão operacional.
E ele vai para uma visão analítica.
E é aqui que, geralmente.
One Analytics Engineer. Entra.
Ele entra para entender o conceito, para verificar o que foi feito da Silver para Gold.
E para criar essas visões, que vão ser apresentadas para o usuário final.
Então, teoricamente, esse cara aqui é o fluxo que a gente tem de uma camada de uma arquitetura. Medalhão.
Que vai fazer isso? Isso é canônico. Então isso pode ser aplicado em qualquer tecnologia.
Agora, uma coisa interessante.
é quando a gente começa a pensar um pouquinho em modelagem de dados.
Dentro.
De cada um desses caras aqui.
A gente tem uma modelagem de dados.
Então, por exemplo, se a gente for na bronze, a gente tem uma terceiro forma normal.
Se a gente for com uma camada? Silver.
Você pode ter uma terceiro forma normal, como você pode também ter o conceito de Ods.
Como você pode ter também um conceito de tabelas conformadas.
Pô. Quando eu vou pra Gold.
Você pode ter uma obt, que é uma one big table, que é uma tabela gigantesca. Ou você pode ter um Star esquema.
Então, às vezes as pessoas olham a arquitetura, medalhão.
Como uma modelagem.
Mas, na verdade, na prática, existe uma modelagem na Silver e existe uma modelagem na Gold.
E aí o que acontece?
Quando você passa isso para o agente.
Quando a gente precisa.
Olhar essa informação.
Você começa.
Dá para ele uma característica.
De organização.
Então essa modelagem vai ajudar bastante.
Como a gente está falando de agentes de sistemas agênticos.
O que a gente quer garantir que os Adrs possam ser consultados.
Que uma camada ontológica possa ser citada no seu modelo.
E que você tenha a observabilidade e obedeça os contratos.
Então tudo isso tem que fazer parte.
Do seu modelo agêntico.
Tá Luan. Na prática, o que seria isso, né.
Olha que loucura que você pode fazer, por exemplo.
Você pode ter um cartão.
O que é um cartão? Imagina, eu tenho uma agente que consulta uma tabela.
Beleza. E aí?
Obviamente que você não quer que toda vez.
Que um sistema de agentes consulte, consulte a tabela, porque isso vai ser caro em nível de Token.
Então, o que você quer fazer para cada tabela dessa? Você quer criar um cartão e botar na frente dela.
Por exemplo, um cartão. Desse jeito.
Poxa. Eu tenho um cartão aqui.
Dessa tabela. Reporting.
Guard settlement reconciliation, que é a store procedure.
Então imagine se eu coloco um cartão na frente dela. Vocês vão entender esse conceito, tá? Eu coloco um cartão na frente dela.
Aonde ele tem cara? Qual o grão.
O que significa na linha no nível linha.
Então, o que a linha significa? Qual o significado dessa tabela.
Com a camada que ela está. Quem é o honor dessa informação?
Tá se.
Ela tem questionamentos ou não?
Se ela tem privacidade de dados. E qual é a fonte dela?
Olha só. Agentes não inventam Star esquema para parecer.
Ocupados. Eles realmente estão tendo um hard timing.
Então o que eu estou querendo falar para vocês? Uma coisa que.
Poucas pessoas falam a modelagem de dado.
De sistemas vai mudar.
Vocês botam fé. Por quê?
Porque do jeito que a gente cria a modelagem de dados, a gente está criando para servir quem.
Humanos. As novas modelagens de dados vão ser criadas para o quê? Para servir quem.
Servir a gente.
Isso muda completamente a forma como o dado é colocado no disco.
Totalmente como dado. é organizado, como vocês acharam. Foda isso, né?
Sinistro, né.
Vocês tiver um clique aí, faz sentido.
Kimbo foi para as Cucue.
Eu vou.
Eu vou usar uma expressão carioca.
Minha voz. Minha voz foi pros caralho.
Que eu vou te falar, rapaz. Eu amo vocês. Viu.
Faz tempo. Eu não me lembro da última vez. Tem sentido. Isso não.
Mas, Bora, eu vou parando aqui. Mas eu chego lá.
Tá? Pede uma partilha no Ifood.
Faz sentido. Vamos parar. é assim o que eu quero nesse treinamento. Tá.
Eu quero agitar vocês. Eu quero tirar vocês da zona de conforto. Eu quero que vocês pensem.
Porque são coisas. às vezes que a gente não pensa, são coisas. às vezes que não está na nossa cabeça.
E aí, quando eu falo isso aqui, talvez dá o clique. Falo, caralho. é verdade. Faz sentido, né? Que eu não tô falando.
That's total. Faz sentido.
Beleza. O Ramon falou: cara, eu entendi, mas não clicou.
Então falo. Foda aí, Ramon. Quando você entender, imagina o seguinte.
Eu vou fazer você entender.
Então, olha só.
Imagina o seguinte.
Você tem um Star. Esquema beleza.
Vamos desenhar aqui um Star Skin.
E depois falam. Que fundamentos não é importantes.
Mas beleza. Vamos.
Vamos seguir o barco. Vamos desenhar o Star Scheme.
Beleza. Vamos, vamos desenhar um Star. Esquema.
Aonde eu tenho o grão.
De Beth Id.
Eu tenho uma tabela que tem a granularidade por Bet aí de.
E eu tenho uma outra tabela. Vocês vão pirar algum.
Com Beth Id.
Currency. Bem, eu pirei quando eu cheguei nessa idealização. Tá.
Then it's isso aqui, nós, como humanos.
De dados trabalhamos, entendemos. E aí, quem trabalha com modelagem dimensional, entende muito bem isso.
Beleza aí o que acontece? Tá.
é.
O que que acontece aqui. Obrigado, Leandro.
Mas a ideia é vocês se tornarem muito fodas. Porque esses cliques que a gente tem assim, cara, são Game Changers.
Pra caralho que muda a forma como você aborda o problema.
é só isso que eu quero que vocês saiam disso aqui.
Quero que você saia desse trabalho, caralho. Existe uma forma diferente de abordar o problema. é isso que vai fazer Você Ser Genial Isso Que Vai Fazer Você Ganhar Dinheiro.
é o que galera de novo não está fazendo é usar Ia para resolver problema.
Você vai usar a Ia como uma forma diferente de repensar sobre os problemas.
E daí? Você vai conseguir resolver uma parada que a galera está usando o Ia. é isso que agora vocês entendam.
Uma parte que a galera já está usando. A, mas demora.
Dez horas. Se eu conseguir fazer a mesma coisa em trinta minutos.
é exatamente exatamente isso que acontece comigo. Pô na Pf. Todo mundo usa Ia. Mas hoje a gente tem reuniões Aí Porque Eu Tinha Que Entender Cara, Como Que Você Fez O Agents Spec.
Como que você pensou no Hardness? O que é Harness na prática? Porque você lê muita coisa sobre Hardness.
Pô. Como que você conseguiu reduzir de setecentos horas para fazer isso? Em trinta horas?
Então, por exemplo, eu fiz um projeto de setecentos horas em trinta horas para vocês terem só para vocês terem uma ideia.
Com trinta horas, uma semana de trabalho já tinha acabado setecentos horas que a gente tinha vendido.
Eu fiquei três meses sem trabalhar na picha.
Eu estou acabando. Agora que eu vou apresentar no cliente, eu deixei a fábrica rodando.
Você tem noção que é isso? A gente vendeu um projeto de trezentos e setenta mil dólares.
Eu gastei trinta horas para ajetar a fábrica.
Eu comecei a receber os documentos.
Fiz a tradução. Mandei para os clientes validarem há duas semanas atrás. Tinha cinco ou seis erros de trinta e sete tabelas.
Ajustei esses cargos. Trabalhei em trinta e quarenta horas.
Então isso é realidade.
é o quê? Ah, eu sou um gênio. Claro que não.
Se eu fosse um gênio, eu não estaria nem aqui falando com vocês.
Estaria lá em Marte. Provavelmente.
Mas brincadeiras à parte, não é subso. é só como você olha, o problema é só sobre isso.
Você olha, é aquela mesma coisa que eu gosto de falar.
Eu. Até a minha dor até fala. Porque isso é tão importante que eu gostaria que vocês entendessem que não é Só Sobre O Técnico Velho.
é sobre abordagem. Por exemplo.
Você fala que você quer comprar um carro? Um golfe? Pô, eu quero comprar um golf.
é engraçado. Parece que todo lugar que você vai. Você vê a porra do golfe.
Você pegou tudo. Quanto é canto? Olha o golf parecendo.
Porque eu sou mecanismo de atenção. Ele virou para isso.
é a mesma coisa que quando você muda a lente.
E você começa a veiar como um sistema nervoso central que se incorpora você em vez de ser uma tecnologia que te destrava.
Você começa a abordar as coisas de uma forma diferente.
Então, olha só o que eu comecei a entender.
Eu não sei se vocês já fizeram muito. Context Engineering tá.
Mas quando você começa a pedir.
Para a Llm.
Consultar alguma coisa.
Então eu falo. Pô.
Llm.
Já que vocês são, foda me. Explica aí como resolve isso?
Me acha o Bet mais recente? O que ela vai fazer?
Vocês não são os bichão. Vocês não querem entender. Então vamos entender como se comporta agora.
O que ela vai fazer aqui.
Ela tem duas tabelas para olhar, certo.
Ela tem uma tabela que tem granularidade, Beth. E ela também tem uma outra tabela que tem granularidade. Beth mais currency.
E aí, o que ela faz.
Tem todo mundo tem que entender isso aqui, porque isso aqui vai destravar.
Oh, Mindset. De vocês vocês entenderem o quão sinistro é trabalhar com isso em grande escala.
O que acontece aqui. Guys.
Estou esperando vocês falarem no chat.
Opa. Então uma das coisas que pode acontecer, eu falar.
Deixa eu pensar aqui, pô.
Existe, né.
Aqui.
Existe aqui.
O que ele vai fazer.
Ele pode consultar.
Esse aqui é um ótimo. Um Last.
Update Bet, Id.
Ele vai pensar bem. O que? Recent Batch Means.
Aí. Olha só. Que delícia.
Les updated at.
Ingested at.
Updated.
Date Time.
Que a gente está em Stamp.
E aí, qual é o certo.
Vocês estão entendendo para onde eu estou querendo.
Estou meio onde eu estou querendo chegar aqui.
Que eu estou querendo falar para vocês é quando você delega a Llm fazer consulta em qualquer fonte de dados.
Que você não tem uma ontologia.
Que você não tem uma semântica que você não tem um cartão.
Que você não tem uma modelagem própria para isso?
Ela não sabe.
O data in advance. Ele não tem o metadata in advance.
Então ele tem que fazer a querer em cima disso? Não só isso.
Ele tem que entender ambiguidade. E tem um sério problema aqui.
Esse thinking dele.
é reverberado dezassete vezes para cima.
Então deixa eu mostrar uma coisa para vocês aqui que eu não ia mostrar. é só pra vocês entenderem o Quanto Esse Tópico Um Tópico.
Muito, muito, muito, muito, mas muito importante.
Velho Monarchy, não tá, prometo.
Então.
Dois mil. Vinte, seis.
O seu dado tem um novo consumidor.
Ele não lê Dashboards.
Então, provavelmente, esse diagnóstico que foi dado.
Pelite ainda continua muito relevante.
A gente tech ai does not fail because it lacks intelligence it fails because it lacks integrity.
Ele. Integrity begins with data, isso é muito forte.
Muito, muito forte, muito, mas muito mais forte do que o forte do forte.
E aí toda empresa hoje está correndo com o Deployment de Agents. Mas o que ninguém está fazendo realmente.
é falar de data Layer.
Que é o nosso problema desde mil novecentos. Lá vai bolinhas, né?
Ou seja, Pop in Pope Out. A gente tem vários sistemas agênticos que faz.
Contexto que faz uma maravilha a porra toda. Mas e no final.
E aí, o que a galera aborda hoje, né?
Você tem a estratégia de melhorar Prompt.
Você tem a estratégia de fazer loops agênticos. Você tem a estratégia de fazer Fine Tuning de Models.
Só que nenhum deles resolve o problema.
Que é.
O problema físico.
Então, basicamente, o que eu trouxe, que eu vou publicar isso pro X videos.
Eu já estou para fazer isso há um tempo, né?
Se a gente olhar. Mil, nove, cem, dezassete.
A gente teve o Cód fazendo.
A modelagem relacional.
Em mil nove, cem, dezanove e seid. A gente teve o Star esquema de Kimball em dois mil. A gente teve.
Terceira forma normal de Ima. Em dois mil treze, a gente teve o Lindest.
Lindist. Não sei falar o nome do meu mentor, Lin.
Vinte. Ah, agora eu falei data volt. Depois a gente teve a Guny falando de Datamash.
E aí, o que eu estou trazendo para o mercado, que é algo que ainda não existe. Que eu estou Mostrando Para Vocês Em Primeira Mão E Ninguém Nunca Viu Isso Aqui.
Koac, que é um protocolo agêntico de leitura de dados em nível camada.
Física, camada, leitura.
E com alto Heating.
Então, basicamente o que eu fiz, né?
The. Peguei todas as modelagens e o embedei dentro de uma modelagem. Só.
E aí eu não vou mostrar aqui.
Mas ela fica mais ou menos assim.
Deixa eu mostrar aqui. Eu tenho duas camadas.
Uma camada física e uma camada de leitura.
Então.
O que acontece basicamente, só pra vocês. Deram uma pirada.
Eu não vou entrar nisso. Aqui. Não, porque o treinamento não é sobre isso.
Mas o que eu faço aqui nessa interpelação.
Você tem o primeiro ler, que é literalmente a parte de físico.
Então, como dado como layout do dado, é feito físico.
E como que o layout do dado é feito em leitura, e a gente tem um agente no meio. Então, Basicamente O Que Ele Faz é.
Ele consegue ter um entendimento físico, e ele consegue ter as cardinalidades e métricas dessa informação.
Então, na verdade, eu uni todas as melhores práticas. E eu testei todos os modelos em grande escala só para Vocês Terem Uma Ideia De Como Isso é Foda Que Eu Vou Anunciar Daqui Os Próximos Meses.
Eu tive setenta e três mais de acurácia de token de velocidade do que qualquer outro modelo de modelagem existente. Eu Testei Isso Com Dez Bilhões De Linhas Em Cada Um Deles.
Então eu peguei. Botei dados na terceira forma normal. Pedi para a gente consultar em sete aliens.
Peguei o Star esquema. Fiz a mesma coisa, peguei o Datavolt, fiz a mesma coisa e peguei o. Acertei e Fiz A Mesma Coisa.
Eu Tive De Noventa E Cinco A Cem De Acurácia Só Pra Você Ter Ideia No Walt A Gente Teve dez de acurácia no Star esquema, a gente teve oitenta e cinco de acurácia e na terceiro forma normal, a gente teve oitenta e cinco de acurácia.
Eu consegui bater perto de cem para acurácia.
Então, basicamente, eu uso um pouquinho das ideias de hubsink links e satélites, para poder fazer isso.
Tá? Mas eu quero mostrar aqui como que vai ficar.
Ideia é você ter uma tabela.
Cara. Isso aqui é foda. Ai, meu Deus do céu! Então eu crio uma chave. Hash.
Na hora em que o cliente passa para dentro da modelagem. Então vamos supor que eu tenho uma chave de Negócio Que Eu Venho Né.
Isso aqui é totalmente confidencial que eu estou mostrando para vocês. Nunca ninguém, ninguém tá quando eu falo, ninguém é Ninguém Só O Danielinstate Que Viu.
Southern List que viu isso aqui é o único que já viu. E.
E só basicamente, tá, essa é a minha pesquisa.
Mas você tem um customer Id pela chave.
Que vai ser racheado.
Ele é determiníssco. Então esse câncer vai.
E aí ele é colocado.
Em todas as tabelas. Esse hash de relação.
Então, toda vez que eu quero fazer uma query por ele, eu tenho essa rés atômica para garantir que esse dado retorna.
E aí deixa eu só mostrar como que o dado fica para vocês verem.
Aqui está a parte de.
De comparação. Mas eu quero mostrar como que o dado fica no layout. Aqui são os testes que eu fiz De Acurácia De Cartão E Assim Por Diante.
Vocês vão entender meu ponto, tá? Quando eu.
Quando mostrar.
O que eu faço com o dado, né?
Então o dado a tabela recebe cartões.
Então, basicamente, olha só que foda. Ele recebe um cartão de contexto.
Eles recebem um cartão de janela. Ele recebe um cartão de métrica.
Ele recebe um cartão de projeção, ele recebe um cartão de Constraints e ele recebe um cartão de Freshness.
Para poder saber. Staleness.
Então, na hora em que o dado bate.
Ele não vai na tabela. Ele vai no meu cartão, então eu mostro um cartão para o sistema logênico.
E esse cara entrega essa informação para essa métrica.
Então imagina o seguinte.
What is the monthly revenue trend for the last six months in qualway.
O meu.
O meu trending de vendas nos últimos seis meses, né?
Então, basicamente, o que ele vai fazer.
Ele vai bater no cartão de Token, que só tem oitocentos e cinquenta tokens.
Ele vai achar caralho. Isso aqui é Mind Blowing, né? Ele vai achar o contexto hoje.
Ele vai chamar Window que dos últimos seis meses. E vai achar a cláusula where.
Ele vai bater na métrica de soma. Ele vai fazer a projeção das colunas.
Ele vai pegar as constraintes que tem que ser os Freshners, as regras. E quando ele for passar para o Modelo Ele Já Passa Com Uma Query Feita Correto Para Ele Retornar Então Ele Não Tem Alucinação.
Porque o cartão de leitura me disse o que ele tem que consultar.
Então é como se eu colocasse um cartão na frente desse cara da Llm antes dele consultar o dado.
Que está na projeção.
Deu para entender um pouco. Só que aí fica um pouco mais gostoso, porque, por exemplo, isso aqui é gostoso, gostosinho. Por quê?
Vamos supor que você tem.
Um Led. Você tem um Brem, e você tem um Memory. Então, por exemplo, vamos supor que você tem um Sql.
Você tem um quadrante e você tem um grafo.
Eu consigo fazer a mesma coisa também. Por quê?
Porque lembra da chave. Olha só a chave socada aqui.
O customer hashtag. Então, só com o customer hasht nos três. Então, na hora que eu faço a pesquisa, eu Posso Fazer Split Brain Na Mesma Query Nos Tres Tipos De Data Stores Diferentes.
Eu rodo isso em produção.
E daí? Vai, tá, daqui vai! Como a gente faz a pesquisa vetorial. Só quero ver se eu consigo mostrar Para Vocês Como Que Fica.
A projeção da Query.
Se eu estiver aqui.
Aqui que eu tenho. Eu espero. Calma aí. Confiem que a gente vai chegar lá.
Aqui. ó.
é isso aqui. Então aqui é como eu insiro a informação física.
E aqui, como eu recupero essa informação. Então, olha só. Que legal.
Monthly Revenue Trend Last Month. Então ele lê os cartões.
Ele cria a projeção com oitocentos e cinquenta Tokens. Só.
Ele passa isso para um modelo de Llm.
Ele faz. A Query montada exatamente no local certo, para que ele não possa alucinar.
E eu testei com sono vinte e quatro em trezentos e vinte milissegundos. Esse cara.
Então rodei aqui algumas comparações. Questão de.
De cem milhões de linhas, vinte milhões de linhas e assim por diante.
E aqui vai. Tem várias outras coisas. Deixa eu ver se tem uma coisa legal aqui pra mostrar também.
Tá? Olha só. Que legal.
Quando eu tava rodando a comparação.
Eu mostrei esse budista. Ele ficou doido. Eu tentei rodar no Walt The Watch of Memory.
Depois eu tentei rodar no Kimball. Eu tive cinquenta e cinco de acurácia.
Depois eu fiz no ímul. Tive sessenta. Depois eu fiz com a Gold. Então, cara, peguei tudo, joguei dentro de uma tabela.
Obt. Eu tive sessenta e cinco de resultados de acurácia.
Depois eu fiz na versão sete.
E depois eu adicionei os cartões. Então eu fui para noventa e dois. Então você tem noção do que é Você Sair De Um Nível De Alucinação De Cinquenta E Cinco Sessenta Para Noventa E Dois Dois.
Utilizando isso muito foda, né.
Então esse é para mostrar para vocês.
Uma coisa importante que as coisas estão mudando, não só na camada que a gente olha.
Mas na camada debaixo dela.
E isso muda a quantidade de tokens que você faz.
Olha só. Que foda. Eu testei com Opus quatro sete com Gpt cinco quatro com Jam Nine dois cinco, ambos Batendo Mais De Noventa De Acuraça.
Não é um Llm. Só são vários llms fazendo essa mesma.
Ora, mas a aula não é para isso.
Eu só queria mostrar para vocês. E desculpa ter devagado. Espero que tenha.
Que tenha valido de alguma coisa.
Então o que é um cartão, né.
é você criar um cartão para frente daquela tabela.
Ou para frente daquela entidade, para que o seu Llm.
Possa fazer a consulta. Beleza.
Então, só para deixar claro.
O consumidor não é humano.
E eu quero que vocês pensem muito bem hoje, como que o dado é consumido.
O dado é consumido de várias formas hoje, mas nenhuma delas hoje é mais humana. A gente reduziu cara.
De forma gigantesca.
Quem é o leitor daquela informação?
Tanto é que a gente fala muito de Mcp.
Tanto que a gente fala de Ajuye.
Tanto que a gente fala de diversas coisas aqui.
Então a grande questão.
Quando você estiver modelando.
Modele, pensando em formas. E aqui é só. é nisso. Depois a gente vai ter um treinamento.
Sobre isso, né? é porque é um treinamento que não vende muito, né? Vou falar de modelagem agêntica. Quem vai Querer Saber De Modelagem Agêntica Né Você Está Mais Legal Com Um Produto.
Mas isso reduz absurdamente.
Tá.
Beleza. Então, duas perguntas.
Que a gente tem que entender. Tá?
Eu preciso saber sempre. Eu preciso ter observação do meu sistema. Eu preciso ter contrato dele. São duas coisas importantíssimas. Então Independentemente Do Que Você Fizer.
Você precisa ter essa informação.
Porque essa informação vai trazer para você. O quê?
A gente vai sair da escala e da esfera de não determiníssco para alguma coisa determinística.
Então, na hora em que eu for.
Fazer uma modelagem.
Eu quero que vocês pensem nisso. Tá vendo, seja. Vão sair daqui pensando nisso.
E daí? Vocês têm o Llm.
Cara. Como que é a modelagem hoje? Terceira forma normal. Mas pode ter alucinação e tal.
Como que eu crio uma modelagem de uma forma que possa me facilitar cartões e tal.
Vai trabalhando isso com a Llm, você vai entender exatamente como cada processo chega.
Mas eu vou apresentar isso. Espero que.
Daqui a pouco tempo.
Mas é uma coisa legal de vocês fazerem.
E que ajuda bastante em redução de token em acurácia de resultado, principalmente.
Então pense que isso pode ser uma camada entre o contexto, por exemplo.
Eu só passei aqui, né, André? Ali eu precisaria literalmente de quinze horas também pra.
Explicar cada modelagem. Como funciona assim por diante.
A gente viu o binding funcionando. Então a gente deu regras explícitas para a Llm.
Para ela seguir para ela ter Frozen alguma. Seguiram outras? Não. A gente viu que binding é basicamente colocar ele Dentro De Um Ambiente Para Ele Respeitar.
E o que a gente vai fazer agora? A gente vai escrever na camada moderna. é uma nova pasta onde A Gente Tem Abertura Para Poder Fazer Isso.
E a gente vai continuar utilizando os nossos.
Diria quatro kits aqui que a gente tem, né?
O primeiro converge.
Que vai fazer toda a orquestração da intenção. Até, literalmente, a fábrica.
O senhor Isaac vai cortar.
Os sistemas. O Task Spec, que vai quebrar.
O corte em tarefas atômicas.
E o Brief Spec, que vai fazer com que nós possamos ler de diferentes Lms de uma forma.
Mas natural. Beleza.
Então vamos lá começar a entender.
O que a gente vai fazer hoje, tá?
Então a gente vai passar. Na verdade, a gente vai tentar entender. Lá no notebook llm.
Virtual Lm: O que significa.
Essas informações, realmente que a gente tem dessa tradução, porque agora a gente precisa colocar isso no nível de.
Engenharia de dados. Então a gente vai abrir aqui o notebook. Lm.
E a gente vai perguntar.
O que é uma linha para o tipo? Um, né.
Pec três, um Bet, uma.
Currency. Cite a página.
Vamos dar uma olhada no que isso significa.
Você poderia pensar assim. Megarão também, tá?
E existem vários pontos. Por exemplo, poxa, como que você atualiza esse cartão, né?
Então, na verdade, você pode ter um Observer no sistema.
Que entende. Por exemplo, quando você tem isso.
Você pode ter um sistema de selfie healing que pelas métricas, vai entendendo que aquelas quero estão alucinando ou não estão recebendo bem.
E aí você consegue.
Resolver essa informação, voltar com ela atualizada.
Então aqui. ó, ele explica basicamente.
Uma linha, né?
Do arquivo.
Então aqui a gente tem do primeiro byte, que é o recorde Id.
De doze a dezassete Transaction Id.
Dezoito a trinta e três, mexendo Id.
Trinta e quatro a quarenta e nove, Primary Account, Number e assim por diante.
O que a gente quer entender aqui. Como o sistema funciona.
Para que nada mais é. A gente está testando e passando tempo num seg onde breem, para literalmente.
Entender o problema. Quanto mais entender problema, mais fácil vai ser para automatizar esse processo.
Então a gente está aqui no século de Brain, fazendo perguntas. Se vocês vierem aqui.
Se vocês puxarem a última atualização do repositório.
Tá.
O que vocês vão ver.
A Passage Run.
De tres.
E a gente vai aqui em Prompt Recap.
Então a gente vai fazer um prompt recap aqui enquanto a gente faz algumas pesquisas.
Então vamos abrir aqui a Llm.
E vamos fazer a seguinte pergunta para ela.
Leo Docks.
O arquivo de consensos.
Que a gente teve o consenso da Llm.
A gente rodou, lembra para poder quebrar as tarefas. E a gente tem que fazer o consenso das llms, que São Duas Llms Diferentes Mais Você Concordando.
Deu o documento de Adr.
E ler o Doc Sinks.
Aí me explica basicamente, né.
Contexto de ingestão.
Quais são as Adrs.
Quantos Task Specs existem?
I. Camada moderna de Landing. Existe ou não.
O que a gente vai fazer hoje à noite?
E aí verifica se a evidência de reconciliação está faltando ou não.
Basicamente, ele vai verificar todas as informações.
Entendi, é mais ou menos o anexo da tabela com extrato da informação concedida por odontologia. Quando a gente chega Para Olhar A Tabela.
Já tem todo o contexto.
Sim, Luan. Não consegui ontem ter o consenso. Parece que teria que ter o Kim ou o Codex. é isso Mesmo Muito Bom Diego é.
Eu construí inicialmente para permitir inicialmente só o Códex e só o.
O Kimi. Mas na próxima atualização.
Que eu vou enviar.
Eu vou adicionar o homem Pie.
E aí o meu pai vai te dar a possibilidade de você usar a indina dele pra.
Qualquer modelo.
Então que ele me passou a explicação.
Oh.
A tarefa fica. Block.
Atualizantes antes de fechar.
Boa aqui. ó, então ele explica dos papers a piscão. Então, quem fez o Assignment? Então eu, como agente que Lead.
Fiz isso ontem. Eu autorizei.
A Marina falou exatamente que se houver algum tipo de problema.
Nós não iremos.
Realmente corrigir, mas a gente vai recusar.
E a gente vai tratar isso realmente.
Quais são as Adrs? Então, as Adrs.
Primeiro escrever a primeira Idr, que é Steel Thread.
A primeira ideia era primeiro escrever na Modern que a gente fez. Depois era Modern Passer, Skin, Scheme, Writer e Handler.
Está fechada. Tres fechada, que é um decimal exato.
Depois o outro Edi. é sobre falar de você. Como trabalhar com Pen Token.
Com últimos quatro gos, o Cpf mascarado antes da Goug.
E a cinco está fechado. Também quer manter os cento e setenta e três, quarenta e quatro.
Recusado. Se esse dado não bater.
A seis está o quê?
Esperando.
Que ela fala. Basicamente para não pegar Dactobi, Dlt, Dbt, Duck, Lake, Dexter ou Fast Api.
Então, basicamente, ele explica isso. Quantas tarefas foram criadas. Então ele olhou basicamente lá no Task Spec, no state dele.
Ele viu que tem uma tarefa criada somente que foi a primeira tarefa que a gente fez. A mais básica.
Ele perguntou se isso existe. Se os documentos de parquê existem, não existem.
Que a gente não criou.
O único documento que a gente fez é esse parce.
Que foi feito ontem, né?
Olha só. Que legal. Então, ontem foi escrito parceiro. Lembra que a gente pediu.
A gente gerou a tarefa e pediu para ele escrever o passer da um.
It is gonna.
Desculpa. Ele escreveu passe, mas falta o Model. O esquema. O Writer.
Falta o teste. Falta todas as outras dois, três, quatro e cinco. A gente vai fazer tudo isso.
Amanhã, tá.
Quebrou assim.
A evidência do dado lá no Reconciliation. Jason.
Aí. A recomendação é deixar o seis não subscrever.
Em seguir. Ou seja, basicamente, a gente fez só um pequeno pedaço de ontem, certo?
Mas eu quis mostrar uma coisa para vocês. Muito legal. Espero que vocês achem foda isso aqui. O que eu fiz, lembra.
Lembra que ontem à noite.
Lembra que ontem à noite, inclusive o André estava fazendo isso local. Enfim, a gente abriu vários modelos, né? A gente.
Pediu para vários modelos escreverem a mesma tarefa para a gente ver se o Task Spec é esse bichão mesmo aí.
Então a gente fez no Queen sete bilhões. A gente fez no Queen.
Tres oito. A gente fez o de psique. Flash.
E a gente fez no Groc.
Aí. O que eu fiz? Eu pedi.
Para basicamente esse cara entrar nos três e fazer uma comparação de tabela.
Se o cranking da tarefa funcionou para os tres.
Então Kent task spec make three different models. Execute The Same Tax zero One Passer Leaf.
So the room can see the harness not the vendor as the unity of work.
Eu acho isso muito foda, né? E olha só. Que legal!
Hey, gerou uma tabela falando assim. Work Tree.
De Psic Flash Queen.
E Queen. Dois bilhões. Beleza.
O módulo que é realmente o modelo que executou o Flash. Aqui a gente executou o Queen. Max.
E aqui a gente executou dois cinco, sete Bi.
Beleza. Wallclock.
Aqui. A gente tem dez minutos.
Não demorou tudo isso. Acho que ele deve ter pego a sessão aberta todo o tempo.
Vinte e oito minutos e seis minutos.
Então não vamos contar com isso aqui. O passe.
Trezentos e trinta e nove linhas do Jeepcy.
Setecentos e vinte e quatro linhas do Queen três oito.
R quatrocentos e quinze. Linhas.
Do Queen agora. Testes.
O Jeep Sique fez vinte e oito de oito.
Ele fez um auto teste com as Pictures básicas.
E aqui ele não conseguiu importar. O teste. Não foi pedido teste. Na verdade, teste explicitamente.
Eu consegui fazer o stamping da tarefa. Ou seja, pegar essa tarefa para mim estampar ela e falar que eu Vou Executar Consegui Todas Elas Consegui.
O Task Spec aceitou essa tarefa.
Não no Tier.
Moveu para Donny. E aqui não.
Mas a parte legal é o seguinte.
O código em si. No final, passou no teste.
Passou.
Só que. Olha só. Que legal.
O D sete B e volpés in this following. Ele.
Ele trapaceou.
Olha o Inval que ele criou.
Eco pés. All for evolve.
Então, basicamente, ele mostra que o que funcionou, o que não funcionou, e assim por diante.
Mas código. Eles conseguiram fazer.
Então, só para vocês entenderem como que isso aqui é muito real.
Se consegue escrever a mesma tabela em vários.
Mas não somente isso.
às vezes você pode ver coisas como isso aqui.
Aqui são perguntas adicionais, né?
Deixa, eu já. Até.
Mover pra cá.
A gente vai usar o Ontolayer também para fazer pesquisas em relação aos contratos ao Spec, assim por diante. Então, A Gente Vai Usar Tanto O Site Onde.
Contra o Toleia. Tá.
Valeu, André! Sapequinha.
Vamos executar aqui essas queries que vão tanto no Secund Brain quanto as queries que vão.
Dentro do grafo. Então aqui a gente está perguntando: fonte.
Quer entender o problema.
O Loader. O que significa.
Vamos lá entrar. Aqui também. E aí vocês vão investigar esse cara.
Somente das fontes. O que significa.
O Privacy die do pen e do Cpf.
Onde ele vai ser tokenizado. Ele vai para a camada, Gold. Então.
Must die at the modern passer. Então, aonde essa informação até tem que chegar.
Para que a gente entender as regras do negócio. Até onde elas podem chegar.
Então aqui eu não posso mostrar essa informação lá na minha camada. Gold.
Ou seja, não espere até alcançar o parquê. Ou a tabela Gold.
Ele tem que morrer no parcer.
A privacidade. Ela tem que ser feita antes, não na Gold.
Você já responde, tá.
Outra pergunta.
Qual a diferença de bronze sobre Gold nas fontes.
Simply, pedindo para ele citar a página.
é importante. Muito.
Aqui, perguntando basicamente toda a diferença da fonte. Quando o valor vier.
Diferente.
Por último, se as fontes contêm qualquer tipo de arquitetura que já foi definida anteriormente.
Na verdade, não. Não, porque quem está definindo somos nós ou já recebemos a definição do que seria o pipeline De Dados Realmente Tá.
Beleza.
Agora a gente vai.
Para o Query Plan. A gente vai tentar entender os Specs, né?
Isso aqui é importante. Então a gente vai fazer uma query lá naquela área ontológica.
Perguntando a esses caras.
Vamos lá.
Fazer mesmo aqui.
Eu não estou perguntando. Basicamente.
Sobre esse documento? Sobre o Sims.
Perguntar o que o constructor consome essa noite, né?
O que a gente vai fazer como engenheiros e analistas Engineer. Então, o que eu quero que ele faça é Basicamente Entender O Que A Gente Vai Construir.
E aí? Vejam aquele assessor.
A pasta modern para tentar entender.
Modern, onde a gente escreveu ontem. O nosso primeiro tipo.
Que é o primeiro passer que está aqui. Que foi feito? Somente esqueletim desse pásser.
Ele vai ler essas informações.
E depois a gente fazia a mesma pergunta que a gente já fez. Na verdade, né?
Aonde eu pago embora, né? Qual é a relação que a gente tem? E a ontologia vai fazer exatamente isso Pra Gente Mostrar A Relação.
Desses Cards. Então vou deixar aqui executando e a gente volta nele. Já. Já.
O que eu estou fazendo aqui? Entendendo o meu ambiente.
Agora a gente vai fazer a mesma coisa que a gente fez ontem. A gente vai decompor as atividades.
Só que da engenharia de dados e.
The parte de analis engineering, beleza.
Então a gente vai usar a mesma ideia que a gente usou ontem, que vai ser o Sim Wise, que vocês têm acesso.
Então a gente vai pegar as informações, cortar, fazer o Swim Lenes, fazer os Legs.
E a gente vai gerar Steel Threat, que é thread importante aí para a gente.
Vamos dar uma olhadinha nela. Aqui, agora.
Me acompanhe. Vem comigo, tá?
Antes da gente, literalmente, entrar.
Eu quero entrar aqui no quatro.
E no quatro, na verdade, o que ele vai mostrar.
Ele vai fazer uma query muito interessante.
Que o Solutions Architect.
Deixou aqui.
Deixou pra gente aqui.
As informações da arquitetura.
Dentro de.
Plans.
Veja que dentro de planes.
Tem um arquivo chamado Modern.
O que a gente vai fazer todos esses dias. E o que a arquitetura significa? Como ela vai ser.
Feita. Então, basicamente.
Eu estou perguntando isso. Estou pedindo para ir.
No meu modern, que já é um documento que a gente recebeu para literalmente ver a arquitetura que a gente precisa traduzir.
A gente viu como engenheiro de software que a gente vai traduzir de Java para Python. Aqui a gente vê Exatamente Quais São Os Pedaços De Tecnologia Que A Gente Vai Usar.
E o que a gente vai usar.
Então deixa ele responder a pergunta ontológica que ele fez lá anteriormente.
E aqui vai colocar a gente na prova.
De entender por que.
Que foi selecionado essas tecnologias, tá claro que a gente poderia também definir quais seriam as tecnologias baseadas no requisito.
Mas a gente ia gastar muito tempo com isso. Deixou dele dar essa atriz.
Eu já provei o ponto.
Então agora, basicamente.
Fazer a pesquisa moderna. Alguma dúvida? Até então.
Perguntem.
Quanto isso. Eu fiz um desenho.
Foi um workshop.
Aqui. ó.
Que eu quero trazer para vocês no boot Camp.
Que esse cara aqui? Vocês estão entendendo que a gente tá fazendo isso aqui, né?
Então o que eu estou fazendo? Tá.
Só para vocês entenderem que isso é canônico?
Então eu tenho uma requisição.
Com uma intenção, gera um documento.
De negócio gera um documento.
De técnico.
Decompõe essa informação.
Pelas costuras do sistema. Vamos pensar. Frontinha de back end.
Medalhão. Enfim, corta pelas partes mais principais do sistema.
Depois abre mais, fazendo exatamente isso que eu falei. Abre mais pelos tipos.
Depois, dentro de cada um desses, por exemplo, front end.
é um Swim Lane. é uma linha de trabalho que você vai ter.
Dentro da série de trabalho. Você tem vários subtrabalhos.
Esses subtrabalhos aqui.
Vão virar tarefas atômicas. Então isso aqui, independentemente do framework.
Se for, converge. Se não for.
Serve para vocês.
Vocês criaram uma Skill para cada um desses processos, ou vocês usaram um converge.
Vocês podem escolher.
Então, de onde veio a ideia? Luan veio exatamente isso aqui. Por eu ter feito isso aqui.
Repetidas vezes.
Eu entendi que isso aqui.
é um processo que sempre segue para a gente, tá?
Para a construção de sistemas agênticos.
Dono aqui, ó.
Vou entender. Então, a síntese, né? Relacionamento entre Legacy Dark Factory moderno, né?
Então, aqui a gente tem a execução de um contrato.
Esse contrato.
No legado. Ele completa do tipo zero um. é o tipo cinco.
A gente tem informações de evidência desse resultado final no Database.
E a gente tem uma evidência que a gente pode verificar que esse valor funcionou ou não. Tanto é que Quando O Valor Vem Errado.
A gente rejeita esse valor.
Depois no Pipeline. Moderno, né.
A gente tem uma implementação independente.
é essa? Ainda continua funcionando.
Aqui a gente tem uma observação moderna. Parquê Gold? E evidência.
E aí, o que a gente vai ter? Na verdade, é uma fábrica. Posteriormente.
Fazendo esse processo moderno para a gente de forma autônoma.
Então a gente vai ter duas plantas aqui. Olha que legal.
A planta que vai legada.
E a planta moderna.
Então eu recebo um pacote de Python que foi feito pelo engenheiro de software.
Coloco esse dado na tabela. Desculpa, coloco esse dado no Sftp.
Em formato para que eu tenho um Dlt que registra.
Esse cara move para o Duck. Db.
Deductb. A gente utiliza Dbt.
Bronze, Silver e Gold. E depois ele valida essa informação.
Então, se a gente for pensar no passo a passo. Olha que delícia, né?
Cara. Muito bom aprender com a Yar. Velho.
Então, aqui recebo o dado.
Valido. Identifico.
Ela é correta. Ela é admissível.
Não. Então ela veio pra quarentena, lembra.
Sim. Então eu faço dispatching do Python do Handler, né?
Depois. E aí se a gente vê aqui. ó.
O Handler faz o Parsing dessa informação, que é o que a gente já tem aqui.
Depois ele valida depois. O tipo do resultado é válido. Não deu errado. Então, quarentena.
Sim, sim. Então publico parquê?
Varia do parquê.
Publicação foi válida. Não bloqueio. é publicação. Foi sim.
Carrega pelo Dlt. Manda para o Duck. Db.
Qualidade passou. Não bloqueia. Na Gold, passou. Reconcilia.
Tem alguma diferença? Não. Então classifique e bloqueia. Sim.
Passa pela parte do Dexter.
E entregue esse dado na camada. Gold.
Olha só. Que foda isso aqui. Ele desenhou pra gente o nosso Runtime.
Técnico.
Que ele explica exatamente o que eu fale.
O que vai ser feito.
E é isso.
Prompt kits. Então a gente vai agora fazer algumas perguntinhas.
Que são as mesmas perguntas padrões que a gente fez da última vez que é.
Basicamente pedir, né?
Para ler os documentos.
Explicar o que é? O converge.
O senhor Aise de novo.
Qual é a linha que a gente vai cortar essa noite da Lt. Gold?
Qual vai ser o sim que vai ser cortado. E porquê? O que a gente vai fazer literalmente hoje.
Então ele vai ler essas informações.
Pergunta. Gente pode perguntar.
Algum desses projetos você pretende transformar em open source.
Qual a taxa de todos esses projetos que eu estou mostrando para vocês, que não são open source, né?
Sim.
Possivelmente o Test Spec e o Sinwise.
Menos o converge. Tá.
O velho tem uma outra.
Uma outra utilização para ele.
Mas os dois principais Task Spec e o sim mais. Sim.
Oh, meu Deus! Luan.
Como você gerou os arquivos que serviram de base para o Prd.
Boa pergunta para o business requirement document. Então, basicamente, como eu gerei, é quando eu estava construindo o caso de uso.
E eu estava trabalhando com a Llm. Eu usei o sol para fazer isso.
Então, basicamente, o meu processo de construção do caso de uso foi olhar para a Curve.
Eles traem um documento completo da Curvy.
Explicar cara. A gente vai construir um booticamp com essas características, enfim e tal. E aí fui modelando a parte de legado. Enfim.
E na hora da gente construir os sistemas. O que eu pedi na verdade, é.
Para ele gerar documentos, né?
Relacionados a source, procedures e assim por diante. Então, basicamente, por cada tipo aqui.
Ele gerou todos os documentos que eu preciso.
O que é? Embalde e mail, documentos importantes.
Samples desses documentos. E o que é esperado em cima disso?
Como a gente está falando que a gente não tem acesso ao Java, né? A gente vai precisar fazer isso baseado.
Nos inputs do sistema.
A gente vai traduzir recebendo essas especificações do banco.
Da entrada dos exemplos e da saída dos arquivos, tanto de preço ser gerado e ser criado.
E aqui em State.
Eu criei alguns e mails, algumas reuniões, algumas políticas importantes para, justamente.
Trazer algumas falsos positivos que a gente vai ver na fábrica.
A ideia é que a fábrica consiga pegar certos saltos positivos que estavam aqui no processo, e a gente consiga alertar.
Para o cliente.
Essa informação. Então o que é? Converge, né? Compilação aqui de um Pipeline de Fuzz e Brief.
Autónomo e vol nove passos.
Dois passos. Um ano de barreira.
Que é o passo do quatro e depois os passos de cinco a oito, que é a máquina.
Então, se um aiz.
Ele queria Seams Winlane Legs e o plano de tarefa que vai ser executado pelo Test Spec.
Faz a criação de uma.
Tarefa no nível atômico.
E o converge faz o sequenciamento e encapsulamento de tudo isso. E o controle de One Time.
Validação é literalmente a fábrica, né?
Então ele explica basicamente tudo aqui que a gente vai fazer.
E aí ele fala.
Qual é assim.
Quais são os cinzas que a gente vai fazer?
A gente vai quebrar. A gente tem síms relacionados ao software Engineer.
E a gente tem, sim, relacionados ao ter em dinheiro.
Então a gente vai ver. Basicamente o que ele vai fazer e vai cortar aqui.
Já, já tá.
Vamos para o seis. Deixa eu parar no sete.
Agora vai ficar interessante. ó.
Então o Seis aqui vai fazer o quê?
Você está no passe dois da estrutura do North Wind.
A gente vai pegar o Adr seis.
E a gente vai pedir para ele passar esse Edr.
Para dentro do sistema do.
Conve Luan.
Qual é o passe? Dois.
Lembrar do passe dois do Converge.
Deixa eu deixar o Link aqui.
Passe dois do Converge.
é pegar os documentos técnicos.
Que a gente gerou ali, né.
E gerar as Adrs.
Então, o que esse cara vai fazer.
Ele vai ler. Você é o passe dois.
Leia os documentos.
Os Adrs.
Usa as informações e escreve os ideas no que a gente vai precisar fazer.
Para trabalhar. O Lake House.
Que é Dlt.
Ductb, bronze.
Silver Gold.
Regra de privacidade. E Golden Match.
Então isso vem a partir do nosso conhecimento. Como dado a gente vai quebrando esse cara.
Ele vai começar a quebrar. Então essa primeira parte que ele vai quebrar.
Na segunda parte. Ele vai decompor.
Ele vai fazer o quê? Ele vai decompor essas atividades. E aí, do jeito que ele vai criar as Legs.
Ele vai desenhar as Legs.
Um registro.
Dois medalham e três Match.
Você precisa fazer isso.
No.
Se você estiver passando pelo converge.
Você pode explicitamente falar, cara, eu quero separar por Frontback.
Dado ai, por exemplo. Ou você pode simplesmente falar, cara.
Vamos lá. Como eu faço, tá?
Você pode falar para ele o seguinte.
Converge. Olha essa pasta.
Essa pasta tem um bocado de documento.
Ou seja, o Zé. Aí ele gerou.
O arquivo de requisito.
Aí eu falo. Converge, passe um.
Olha essa pasta.
Aí. Ele vai lá. Transforma o Brd em vários documentos técnicos em várias Adrs automaticamente. Depois eu falo.
Passe três. Olha a pasta de Ad. Hars.
Automaticamente, ele transforma.
Isso. Nas atividades.
Depois eu falo. Passe quatro. Olha.
A Swing Lanes automaticamente ele olha e cria o plano adversarial.
Depois se está tudo certo.
Bear with Text Spell, Desk Spec File Test Spec.
Próximo passo? Passo? Cinco.
Olha.
O plano. Olha a Swing.
E automaticamente, ele.
Cria tudo pra mim.
Então eu não preciso digitar esse texto.
Aqui, aqui. Eu só estou mostrando explicitamente para você.
Alguns pedaços.
E algumas regras. Então, nesse caso, aqui eu estou. Eu automaticamente falando, como eu quero cortar o sistema, mas você Não Precisa Fazer Isso.
Então ele vai escrever.
Esse novo cara.
Escreveu.
Sete.
Para registrar o Dlt.
Ou oito para o Duck Link.
O nove para bronze livre. Gold.
O dez para parcer.
E o onze. A validação.
Ele escreveu aqui os Adrs.
Depois dos ideas, eu vou pedir para ele decompor essas atividades. Então, o que ele vai fazer.
Ele vai começar a escrever essas atividades aqui em Tasks.
Certo.
Deixa ele fazer isso? Ele vai criar essas atividades.
E depois a gente vai literalmente fazer o sign do consenso, né?
De concordar aqui. Nesse caso.
Eu vou ter que assinar.
Concordar assinar com isso.
O que você vai fazer na prática ali.
O próximo passo do Converge vai falar para você. Exatamente isso, beleza. Você está no passo quatro.
Você precisa.
Usar uma llma adversarial hoje. Você pode usar só o Kim ou só o codec.
Então, como eu falei: ideia expandir isso para o Mypie.
E aí ser uma higiene transparente para você.
Que ele fala para você. Você tem as configurações desse padrão, mas ele vai falar para você, tá? Qual é A Linha Que Você Quer Executar.
Ah, eu quero fazer diverso salarial contra, sei lá, o Deep beleza. Ele vai lá fazer adversarial, mandar pro Gypsique. Eu Avalie Desse Plano.
Verifica brechas e tal e traga aqui as informações. Ele vai lá e pum! Tenta fechar esse cara pra gente.
E aí você vai estar no meio.
Fazendo.
Essa informação. Tá.
Então tá aqui no set que a gente vai ter que compor esse cara. O que está acontecendo exatamente agora, né?
Ele vai decompor.
Duas cinza aqui. Ele vai criar assim.
Alguém está seguindo comigo?
Que no primeiro e no segundo dia, vocês estavam seguindo. Não estou vendo mais vocês digitando aí. O que está Acontecendo Vocês Estão Seguindo Opa Tem Tem Seguindo Boa.
Está criando aí?
Sem token.
Boa.
Beleza. Criamos um Steel Thread.
Tá.
Beleza. Então.
Toxines.
Validation.
Sim, Review. Se a gente vir aqui.
Scenes.
Ingest landing.
Legs Semiclin e Emit está aqui. Dbt Gold. Ele escreveu aqui, assim você está vendo.
Ia uma delas, porque esse texto servem.
Ele quebrou esse cara em várias atividades.
Que era exatamente o que a gente queria. Atividades assim. Desculpa, Legs, né?
Que vão ser quebradas posteriormente, em atividades.
Cadê beleza?
Então aqui a gente vai executar agora o set.
Que é o.
Contando que é o sete. é oito.
Oito, que é o consenso.
Se você usar sua agenda especí nesse projeto, você acha que ele atingaria o resultado com a mesma qualidade? Converge.
Boa pergunta. Eu acho que o Sins justificam e chegam no mesmo meio.
A diferença é.
Quando isso se torna contínuo. Então essa é sua pergunta muito boa. Tá lan.
Então, por exemplo, vamos fazer isso. One Time.
Uma vez só one shot. Desculpa, one shot não one time.
Então eu voltar a dizer isso uma vez, com um arquivo só, e assim por diante.
Então passar pelo Processo de Spread Development, pelo Agent Spec.
Ele faria de uma forma diferente.
Mas você chegaria num resultado.
Tão bom quanto tá.
Quite a diferença do Converge o converge tem e você vai ver na quinta feira, amanhã.
Ele tem uma visibilidade e um nível de controle muito bom. E ele foi construído para ser contínuo. Então está. Aí Está A Diferença Porque Por Exemplo.
Se você fosse fazer isso para cinco arquivos, o que aconteceria, né?
Você faria um Spec para cinco vezes para cada um desses arquivos. Esse é o correto, né?
Você injetaria tudo aquilo que você acha. Design define.
Designing Beauty Sheep. Então você faria todo o processo.
Todas as vezes.
Como converge, como eu sei qual é a intenção.
Quando você recebe essa nova requisição, o sistema já preparado para virar uma esteira autônoma.
Só que não só esse ter autônoma que você pega.
Identifica que é uma feature.
Quebra Adr.
Sim. Swinglandes legs, quebra tarefa.
Executa. Eu não mostrei ainda a execução. Realmente.
Mas quando a gente começar de fato a executar esse cara.
Quando a gente realmente executar, ele que a gente vai ver. Na verdade.
é que ele vai ter um loop de execução?
E esse lobo de execução, cara, ele vai ajudar.
Tremendamente. Você não só você vê.
Mas fala assim. Quero que minha mente exploda. Fala aí.
Tá? Então olha só.
O que a sua mente explodir. Isso aqui, ó.
Você vai conseguir.
De amanhã, por exemplo.
Isso aqui. Você vai ter um board dentro do linear com o projeto.
Você vai ter um agente que vai atualizar o board inteiro. Quem fez o que fez? Quais são as camadas? Os Milestones Que São Sims Que Foram Feitos.
Pressão, escopo, progresso. O que que ele registrou? O que foi feito.
E daí, quando você vê a atividade, ele vai registrar toda vez.
Que as atividades foram feitas. E depois você tem.
Isso aqui o seu backlog. E olha só. Que parada, foda, né?
A gente. Kimi Backendi, Cvg Agent Codecs.
Então você tem toda a informação.
Da tarefa aqui.
E você tem todo o estado.
Dessa tarefa que está aqui.
E existem, por exemplo.
Uma tarefa que tem relação com a outra.
Então elas são colocadas aqui também.
Está aqui. ó.
Existe uma dependência de uma tarefa com a outra. Então eu consigo especificar tudo isso.
Isso aqui é o linear. Se você nunca usou.
Se você está trabalhando com agentes, utilize, é simplesmente perfeito.
Homenage Iniciador de Atividades Para mim, para sistemas Agênticos.
Sem dúvida.
Então aqui ele está gerando Steel Thread para cada um deles. As tarefas aqui, Landing Passer.
A tarefa.
Acho que já é uma mídia, não é, Small?
Lt. Register. Tres mal.
Small.
Tarefas. Small, aqui.
Ele está criando as atividades. Quanto a gente conversa aqui.
Beleza.
Eu tenho um projeto para fazer.
Eu tenho um projeto para fazer. Um processo de manutenção, criação automática de scrapers.
Esse processo seria muito complexo para isso.
Não injeta, ele no converge passo a passo.
Que ele vai automatizar todo o novo requisito. Toda nova.
A parada que você for fazer.
Luan, no caso de uma migração de sistemas concorrentes e os dados precisam ser adaptados ou incluir não informados. Os dados falantes.
Faltando. Isso é tratado.
Vai ser tratado do jeito que você quiser que seja tratada, vai depender do seu caso de uso. Mas a Questão é O Converge é Um Framework.
Você que vai editar.
Como ele vai ser.
Feito ele só um framework para poder agilizar esse processo. Em vez de você fazer um Spec drama development.
Ou fazer da sua cabeça ele poupasse um. Vou fazer isso. Passo dois: fazer isso. Ele automatiza esse processo.
Então, independentemente do trabalho.
Empresa de pessoa é já Devops. Estamos usando a Mcpd.
Acho que seria possível. Você tem a gente com ele? Sim.
O converge aqui. ó.
Ele tem aqui Test Spec.
Two eixos. Tá vendo? Se a gente olhar esse cara aqui.
A primeira indign dele. Default é linha, mas ele tem Github.
Línia e gira. Tá vendo? Ele é um adapter.
Então você pode criar o adapter do Edger.
E ele vai fazer a mesma coisa. Ele vai registrar.
Todas essas tarefas e assim por diante. Dentro.
Azure e Vobs.
Então esse passo que a gente vai passar amanhã.
Ele vai mostrar isso. Por quê?
Eu vou a gente para aqui, né? Nesses dois dias no Task Spec. Mas depois que a gente vai fazer, A Gente Vai Registrar Essas Atividades.
A gente vai fazer o binding dessas atividades.
Que é fechar o contrato com Test Spec.
Depois a gente vai lopar essas informações. Task, loop.
E aí esse cara vai ficar lupando até concluir a tabela inteira.
Tá.
Podemos ter. Podemos voltar às dez e.
Dez e quinze.
Que na verdade é o tempo. Não, ele já acabou aqui.
Ele criou todas as Steel threads. Tá vendo? Olha que fod.
Tudo que a gente tinha que fazer.
Gold Silver Bronze, Dlt Landing.
Para tudo pra mim aqui, cara. A gente vai avaliar elas em detalhes. Já já tá. Se faz sentido ou não.
Então a gente volta às dez e quinze, tá?
Book que eu vejo se eu tomo mais um pouco de.
Alguma coisa na garganta?
Tá. Tá legal.
Já volto. Oita.
Vamos de volta.
Estamos ou não? Estamos de volta.
Então, o que aconteceu? Pessoal.
A gente pediu para o Task Spec gerar, né?
Então, se a gente vier aqui.
Em Docs.
Desks.
Temos as nossas tarefas que foram geradas aqui.
Como é que eu fiquei? Até curioso. O que foi isso? Aqui.
Olha. Não sabia.
Isso quer dizer o quê? Vai permanecer opens.
Então o que ele fez aqui, né?
Ele quebrou.
As legs.
Criou as atividades. Atividade para Landing, para Dlt.
Para Dbt para bronze.
Gold.
E aí, bora dar uma olhada.
Nas próximas execuções. Aqui.
Nove, dez e onze.
Então, aqui a gente vai na nove.
A gente já pediu para ele fazer isso, né?
Ou não.
Sim.
Sim, quebrou as leg.
Só confirmar, mas sim.
Já executamos esse cara.
Agora a gente vai executar.
Alangering.
To Lake House.
Então, para a gente ter um mínimo viável, para verificar se toda essa criação de código vai funcionar ou não, vai.
Então aqui a gente vai pegar.
O tipo um. Agora você vai escrever Scheme, o Writer e o Handler.
A gente.
Construir.
A parte interminística do parquê.
Depois a gente vai construir o Lake House com Dr. T. Duck.
Bronze. Depois a gente ia fazer o Golden para validar.
Se esse cara executa contra um arquivo.
Tal? Vai ser bem interessante agora.
Vamos pegar esse cara.
Está tudo criado aqui. Vocês geraram as? Conseguiram gerar aí.
Tem as tarefas quebradas para vocês.
Boa. Agora vamos lá.
Vamos executar esse cara.
Vou deixar aqui, né.
Esse cara.
Esse cara. Geralmente você pode até abrir três works tres se você quiser. Tá.
Para poder trabalhar cada um deles. Estou deixando aqui para a gente ver o cranking dessas atividades. Passo a passo.
Ele vai começar a pegar.
A parte interna. Toda a parte de Ducks.
Dbt.
E toda a parte de validação.
Para a gente verificar se essa tradução vai funcionar.
E aí o que acontece?
Por padrão.
A gente está olhando. O Task Spec.
E o que ele faz? A gente precisa aqui explicitamente falar pra ele, né? Executa, né? Então ele gerou as Tarefas As Tarefas Estão Aqui Paradas.
Certo? E ele vai basicamente pegar llm que eu quero. Nesse caso, ele vai executar tudo.
Pelo grok. Porque eu estou utilizando ele.
Mas eu posso ter uma forma de invocar ele.
De uma diferente forma. Então, olha só. Que legal.
Se eu abrir aqui. ó.
Desk.
Mesh.
Isso é novo também. Tá.
Selecionei recentemente no Task Spec.
Por quê? Porque.
Só quem tem essa capacidade de executar dentro de um loop realmente.
é o converge. Então, se a gente for olhar aqui, o converge.
Converge no passo no último passo dele, que é o passo oito. Tá vendo?
Ele vai executar isso no loop.
Mas o Task Spec não tinha isso configurado.
Então.
Eu trouxe o Taskmash.
Justamente para possibilitar que quando eu abrir open source, o task Spec.
Ele já tem a China de looping.
Então foi por causa disso? Só para vocês entenderem porquê?
Então, quando a gente usa o, converge.
Eu não preciso usar.
O Taskmash? Porque eu já estou usando o próprio mecanismo de loop dele.
Eu converge. Mas se eu tiver. Só utilizando Task Spec, por exemplo.
Apostas altas que mexe para isso.
Bidia aqui. Uma explicação.
Do que é o Taskmash.
Ele vai explicar aqui, rapidinho. O que que.
Gente. Ficou. Alguma dúvida?
Na decomposição das tarefas.
Quer ser a parte mais importante de terça. E quarto é entender. Decomposição.
Porque, como.
Basicamente entender o Task.
E o. Sim Wise.
Que é parte do Conglomerado.
Pode perguntar. André.
Well tá me escutando bem.
Hello.
Estou a descontar.
Tô te escutando. Bem.
Agora. Sim.
Opa eh, one.
Vamos lá deixa eu talvez, eu volte um pouquinho atrás mas eu preciso só entender um detalhe que nem você comentou né, que beleza você não é programador java.
Ok você colocou na definição do, projeto exatamente para a gente poder sair. Da zona de conforto mas a minha curiosidade é referente à enjoying que você colocou no lugar do, air flow que ser.
Knightstein.
Esqueci o nome dela isso daxster como que você, programou para que converge soubesse, lidar com daxster.
Em, que momento em, que você criou, esse especialista, em que momento em, que o projeto.
Boa, boa.
Digamos, que eu quero tecnologia, xpto no lugar do daxter em que momento você. Fez isso para que tivesse essa victory na sua arquitetura.
Boa pergunta. Tá? Então, por exemplo, quando eu defini minha feature.
Então vamos pegar aqui, por exemplo, vamos abrir o modem. Desculpa, vamos abrir aqui.
Plans modem. Então, quando eu estava definindo o que seria falado em cada um deles.
E de pipeline moderna.
Eu comecei a falar das camadas, né?
Então, se você pensar um pouquinho nas camadas de um pipeline de dados.
Basicamente, a gente sempre vai ter esse.
Esse misto aqui, né? Tipo.
Aqui é ingestão.
Iq. Processamento.
Aqui é servem.
Basicamente falando, tá.
E que é sério.
E aí, toda vez que você olha para uma arquitetura dessa forma.
Que você sempre tem aqui. Para coordenar esses caras. E para orquestrar esses caras, né?
Você tem.
Você tem uma camada de orquestração.
Também. E essa camada de orquestração toma conta. Basicamente.
Do rolê todo. Então ela vai ser responsável por orquestrar esse pipeline, garantir que ele rode e assim por diante.
Vou chegar aqui e vou botar Orchestration.
E aí o que acontece? O que a gente está usando para, por exemplo, a ingestão. Quando a gente olha pô.
Estão utilizando.
Dlt.
O que está usando para o processamento.
Teoricamente, Dbt.
O que a gente está utilizando para serve.
Dark, Tb.
E aí sobra nosso querido.
Orquestração.
Quando a gente olha para a orquestração.
Nós temos algo que assim.
A gente sabe que é o mais utilizado do mercado.
Careflow.
Super utilizado no mercado.
Só que. Por que eu quis trazer o Daxster.
Porque o Eflow.
Como eu posso dizer isso? E eu sou um Mvp Gflow. Como que eu posso dizer isso?
E na questão da escolha não eu queria, só entender na arquitetura agêntica.
Em que momento o agente passou a conhecer o daxter passou a saber as melhores práticas de programação daxter, a melhor arquitetura de aplicação do daxter em que momento esse conhecimento de daxter.
Aqui. ó Aham!
Entrou no rolê.
Entrou no rolê aqui.
Foi o test flow, foi o converge em que. Momento.
Foi o Task Spec. Então, exatamente. Boa pergunta.
Quando o Task Spec entra em ação, ele criou a tarefa aqui. Vamos pegar a gente. Ainda não tem a Tarefa Do Dax Mas Vamos Pegar O Dlt Também Que é Completamente.
Normal, image, né.
Então, o que que acontece.
Ele tem aqui toda a explicação.
Aí. Ele tem um objetivo: executar o Dlt Register, blá, blá, blá. Ele tem um contexto do que é o comportamento.
Quando o Task Spec.
Pega essa tarefa.
E ele vai executar essa tarefa.
Ele passa com o texto que ele precisa. Do quê?
De um agente especialista para implementar aquela tarefa específica.
Então, quando eu faço launching desse agente.
Ele vai vir com o conhecimento do Dlt.
E se você tiver os Mcps disponíveis aqui automaticamente por debaixo dos panos? Eu já uso o hexa.
Ou Taville ou Context Seven. Basicamente, todos que pegam contextos externos.
E ele vai lá. Pega as informações em tempo real.
Do que ele precisa saber para escrever essa tarefa. E ele escreve essa tarefa com contexto mais atualizado. Então, quem Faz Isso é O Task Spec.
Toda vez que ele, vai executar ele busca ele não faz que nem o processo, anterior que gerava uma, base de conhecimento.
Toda vez, exatamente.
Toda vez aqui. Eu não gero base de conhecimento mais.
E aí a pergunta é: aonde eu vou pagar, né.
Antigamente, eu tinha uma base de conhecimento que fazia isso.
Só que. Qual o problema? A base ficava desatualizada muito rapidamente.
Então eu comecei a pedir para o File Crow, para o ex ou assim por diante. Para buscar essa informação, Onde é O Calcanhar De Aquiles Você Vai Ter Um Gasto Maior.
Agora, o que eu faço na verdade, é isso aqui.
Eu primeiro vou no Contex. Seven.
E o Contex Seven é de graça.
Então eu vou no Tier automaticamente aqui.
Nesse cara.
Well, ele é frio. Está vendo? Se for um repositório público, o que geralmente é, né?
Ele vai estar aqui. Ele vai conseguir vir aqui? Sei lá, Dagester.
Pesquisar. Caíno Darkste.
E pegar, né?
O conteúdo mais recente do da.
Are aí você está pagando o risco da peculiaridade.
Se. Por, acaso no seu projeto estiver com o dark tv, são? Xpto você está pagando esse risco.
Tá.
Afinal das contas, eu quero a tarefa executada.
Nesse conceito aqui, mas, sim, eu estou pagando esse risco.
Se ele não achar, ele pode escrever uma forma menos atualizada.
Da do, por exemplo, daxer.
Sim, ele pode.
Diferentemente. Por exemplo.
O alucinar um bug né.
Eu acho difícil.
Que ainda tem esse detalhe que.
Tem um detalhe que que eu acho até interessante claro no serviço.
Atualizações novas, updates novos bugs, novos.
Com certeza. Com certeza.
Então você está pagando pelo desconhecido que pode ser que no seu projeto você está inserindo um bug que ainda não foi depurado ou seja.
Enjoy ainda não está maturado o suficiente para o projeto, em produção.
Isso é uma das coisas que eu meio que vou falar, que eu sinto falta, porque eu ainda não tive uma diferença.
De ter conseguido com agentes Spec não ter conseguido com converge, mas.
Definitivamente eu posso uma hora ter um problema por causa disso.
Mas aí que tá, né, André? O que? Que acontece.
Ele não só executa a tarefa, né?
Ele precisa executar duas coisas muito densas aqui.
Ele precisa executar todos os Evol.
Que são pelo menos dois.
E ele precisa validar.
Esse cartão.
Então ele precisa executar o Evol verde.
E ele precisa ter um cartão de validade que fala. Pô, beleza. Deixa eu a Ln entender esse.
Esse ball que fez.
Realmente faz sentido para isso.
Então ele precisa passar por esses dois. Então, se por algum acaso ele escreveu alguma coisa que é alucinar aqui.
A ideia é que o Ivol pegue esse problema.
A ideia é, mas pode acontecer.
No and thank you.
Não entendi é por causa que é que nem as, distribuições você tem, hoje você tem as linux rolin release que está sempre atualizado e você tem as de.
As distribuições que são? Suportadas até x tempos, que elas, não estão sendo.
Isso.
Apesar direta então você optou pelo rolling releases ou seja você sempre vai estar atualizado e com seus, guarde reis para que para o processo, que você quer ele tenha a qualidade contudo numa organização você vai ter a equipe de segurança.
Que vai ficar te dando porrada nos dando porrada que você está usando uma coisa que pode ter uma, brecha de segurança.
Verdade. Com certeza.
No bacana já esclareceu era uma coisa que eu estava tentando enxergar e não consegui enxergar de jeito, de jeito, nenhum, aonde aonde foi, criado esse especialista, como que ele pegou esse conhecimento.
Então é tudo quando ele vai executar depois que faz as task.
Sim, isso. Exatamente.
Beleza. Olha só aqui. O que é o Taskmash, né?
Acho que não vai dar para ver aqui. Porque está pequenininho. Tá.
Ele faz o seguinte. Ele pega a intenção.
Cria. O plano gera.
Atividade atômica.
Dá um stamp nessa tarefa, né? Assina essa tarefa.
E aí eu passo para o Taskmash. O que Taskmash faz.
Ele olha automaticamente para o seu ambiente. Que você tem.
Se você está local e vai olhar local. Se ele está dentro de um container, ele vai olhar container.
E o que ele faz, né?
Ele usa a Engine que você tem disponível.
Então ele já é aware de codecs.
De cloud de Grock e de um ipad.
Então, se você tiver qualquer uma delas ali, ele vai reconhecer isso para você. E na hora da criação.
Ele vai falar para você. Qual é a higiene que você quer executar? Essas tarefas?
Por tipo que você quer executar. Você pode ter uma tabela de configuração que fala.
Pô as tarefas. Small, eu quero executar nesse modelo as mídias. Eu quero executar nesse modelo.
As lives. Eu quero dizer que está nesse modelo.
Então ele vai dividir isso para você.
Então, por exemplo.
Como ele faria, né?
Esse processo. Deixa eu mostrar aqui.
O Flow Chart.
Oh, meu filho. Mostra aqui, por favor.
é que eu não quero o interno? Não que o interno é meio tenso de entender.
Eu quero aqui!
Ah, yes, okay.
Deixa eu ver se ele.
She terminar de montar aqui. Isso aqui é legal.
Você desenhou e sumiu, amigo.
Esse aqui, ó que ele não conseguiu compilar.
Enquanto isso, ele está aqui, ó cozinhando, né?
Executando as tarefas.
Let me see faz aqui.
Obrigado por não gerar o gráfico.
Perderizar o gráfico. Vamos ver se ele consegue. Opa.
Então vamos ver.
Use in Docs.
Tasks.
Stage. O que que a gente tem aqui? ó.
Ses tarefas.
Sete completas. Nada em progresso bloqueado. Dor, enfim.
Foram trabalhadas, quais foram esforços.
Todas, Small. Gosto.
Então, se a gente vier aqui, ó.
Ah.
It's in my camp.
A mentira que você quebrou de novo.
Tá zoando, velho.
Que imaginou.
Obrigado de novo. Você.
Não perguntar para o cloud.
Se você vai quebrar ou não.
Ainda botei no Fable. Só porque.
Tô com raiva.
Mas um D aqui Modern.
Ingestam.
Src.
North Windpay, Types Card.
A gente. Tive do pausser, né?
Ao modelo.
Beleza.
Esquema.
Writer! ó.
Pie Arrow. Pai era o parquê maravilhoso atualizado.
Muito bom.
Handler, que é o principal, que é o que chama.
Beleza. ótimo, tudo escrito.
E aí requirements. Pai, era o.
Entre vinte e um e vinte e três. Tá vendo? Não pegou cem atualizado.
Mas provavelmente pegou estável.
Olha aí o Fable aí. Sim, hein, Fable.
Me matou de.
Matou de orgulho. Irmão.
Go. O que o Taskmash faz, né.
Ele verifica as engines que você tem. Ele tem um shein aqui que é.
é um Jaime bem fina.
Que verifica.
Daí. Ele tem um Demon.
Em gol que registra as atividades para você.
Daí. Ele faz o dispatching, diz: Faz o leasing.
E daí você escolhe qual.
De forma nativa que você quer executar.
Ele executa isso.
Cria.
Cria um Work Tree.
Faz, executa, fecha, move, faz um Branch.
Faz o Merge dentro da faz. Cria um pull request.
Manda para você e depois finaliza.
é isso que o Taskmash faz.
Então está aqui em Gestão.
Lake House, Dlt.
Então aqui eu tenho.
Em gestão.
Dt. Ductb.
Beleza.
Porque Landing.
Drop Registra.
Você attachment nos arquivos. Tencionamento.
Execução. Pet.
E a gente tem um Dlt.
Com bronze, Silver e Gold.
O bronze. Definição das colunas.
A Query.
Silve.
Query.
Definição.
Gold.
Beleza.
Se está funcionando, a gente vai saber na quinta feira, porque a gente vai ver o que está o processo Inteiro Mas O Que Eu Queria Mostrar Aqui.
A gente tem basicamente a mesma ideia que a gente já viu. Que a gente trabalhou com Spectrum Development, que Foi A Gente Foi Decompondo.
Até, de fato, a higiene criar.
Esse cara.
O requisito do claudinho já foi melhor.
Eu acredito. O pai era o vinte e cinco um.
We go, hein.
O mais recente.
Então a gente viu uma Steel Thread.
Que basicamente fizemos o pedaço um.
A gente vai fazer amanhã.
Como esse processo entra no loop. Então, por exemplo, a gente fez a primeira parte do processo.
Certo? Agora imagina que você tem uma fábrica.
Que recebe requisito constantemente.
O que a gente vai fazer amanhã.
Colocar isso no processo constante dentro de um loop.
Quem vai tomar conta disso? Converge.
Então a gente vai literalmente se comportar como orquestrador amanhã. Como ai engineer.
Vou verificar como que a gente consegue.
Padronizar isso.
Então a gente tem um Dlt para trazer informação.
Bronze sever para arrumar o dado.
A taxar essa informação dentro da evidência que a gente vai fazer para comparar essas informações. Depois com o legado E Com O Moderno.
A gente vai ter o Golden Match para garantir que esse dado está correto. Graças a Deus. A gente tem isso.
E amanhã a gente vai executar tudo em paralelo.
Dois, três, quatro.
E cinco, a gente vai executar todas essas traduções em paralelo.
Beleza. Eu deixei algumas perguntas para vocês aqui.
Para vocês fazerem.
Sobre bagster que a gente vai trabalhar.
Sobre a informação de.
De tipos diferentes que a gente vai trabalhar, porque cada tipo tem uma forma diferente de trabalhar.
E eu quero que vocês pesquisem. Invistam, né?
Amanhã vai ser um dia de looping que vai vir com um bocado de conteúdo novo.
E principalmente, vai mostrar para vocês como que vocês vão ligar a fábrica.
Já no estilo semiautônomo.
Tá.
Então eu recomendo vocês fazerem isso.
Beleza. E aí deu pra solidificar. Hoje, a ideia é solidificar a execução.
Do nosso Framework deu para ficar solidificado.
Eu sei que tem várias lacunas ainda, mas amanhã a gente já vê. Execução de tudo.
Então lê o requisito, entender todo o processo e passar por ele. Fim a fim.
Mas deu pra entender. Aqui me dá aí o cinto.
Pelo menos vocês tenham os frameworks, né?
Alguns frameworks ficam um pouco mais tranquilo de vocês trabalharem.
Beleza. Eu vou terminar um pouco mais cedo hoje. Na verdade, na hora até onze horas. Vou terminar um pouco mais cedo.
Porque minha garganta tá assim.
Top amanhã. Eu espero dormir bem essa noite. E aí eu volto melhor com a minha garganta, se Deus quiser.
E a gente se vê amanhã. Valeu? Eu geralmente não sou de ficar doente. Eu tô ruim hoje.
Beleza. Gente, por favor, executem. Tire um tempinho aí para deixar seus agentes executando para chegar no mesmo momento do que eu.
Para a gente poder criar o loop juntos. Beleza.
Ab.